welcome to the hubermann lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
[Music]
i'm andrew huberman and i'm a professor
of neurobiology and ophthalmology at
stanford school of medicine
today we are going to discuss light and
the many powerful uses of light to
optimize our health we're going to
discuss the use of light for optimizing
skin health appearance and longevity for
wound healing for optimizing hormone
balance and for regulating sleep
alertness mood and even for offsetting
dementia
one of the reasons why light has such
powerful effects on so many different
aspects of our biology is that it can be
translated into electrical signals in
our brain and body into hormone signals
in our brain and body and indeed into
what we call cascades of biological
pathways meaning
light can actually change the genes that
the cells of your bodies express and
that is true throughout the lifespan
today i will discuss the mechanisms by
which all of that occurs i promise to
make it clear for those of you that
don't have a biology background and if
you do have a biology background i'll
try and provide sufficient depth so that
it's still of interest to you and i
promise to give you tools very specific
protocols that are extracted from the
peer review literature that will allow
you to use different so-called
wavelengths which most of us think of as
colors of light in order to modulate
your health in the ways that are most
important to you for those of you that
are thinking that the use of light to
modulate health falls under the category
of wu science pseudoscience or
biohacking well
nothing could be further from the truth
in fact in 1903 the nobel prize was
given to neil svinson he was icelandic
he lived in denmark for the use of
phototherapy for the treatment of lupus
so there's more than a hundred years of
quality science emphasizing the use of
light
and as you'll soon see the use of
particular wavelengths or colors of
light in order to modulate the activity
of cells in the brain and body
so while it is the case that many places
and companies are selling
therapies and products related to the
use of flashing lights and colored
lights
promising specific outcomes from
everything from stem cell renewal to
improvement of brain function
and some of those don't have any basis
in science there are photo therapies
that do have a strong foundation in
quality science and those are the
studies and the protocols that we are
going to discuss today but i thought
that people might appreciate knowing
that over a hundred years ago people
were thinking about the use of light for
the treatment of various diseases and
for improving health and indeed many of
those therapies are
used today in
high quality hospitals and research
institutions and of course clinics and
homes around the world one of the more
exciting examples of phototherapy in the
last few years is the beautiful work of
dr glenn jeffrey university college
london the jeffrey lab is known for
doing pioneering and very rigorous
research in the realm of visual
neuroscience and in the last decade or
so they turned their attention to
exploring the role of red light therapy
for offsetting age-related vision loss
what they discovered is that just brief
exposures to red light early in the day
can offset much of the vision loss that
occurs in people 40 years or older and
what's remarkable about these studies is
that the entire
duration of the therapy is just one to
three minutes done just a few times per
week what's even more exciting is that
they understand the mechanism by which
this occurred
the cells in the back of the eye that
convert light information into
electrical signals that the rest of the
brain can understand and create visual
images from well those cells are
extremely metabolically active they need
a lot of atp
or energy and as we age those cells get
less efficient at creating that atp and
energy
exposure to red light early in the day
and it does have to be early in the day
allowed those cells to replenish the
mechanisms by which they create atp i'll
talk about these experiments in more
detail later in the episode and the
protocols so that you could apply those
protocols should you choose but i use
this as an example of our growing
understanding of not just that
phototherapies work but how they work
and it is through the linking of
protocols and mechanism that we meaning
all of us can start to apply
phototherapies in a rational safe and
powerful way i'm pleased to announce
that i'm hosting two live events this
may the first live event will be hosted
in seattle washington on may 17th the
second live event will be hosted in
portland oregon on may 18th both are
part of a lecture series entitled the
brain body contract during which i will
discuss science and science-based tools
for mental health physical health and
performance i should point out that
while some of the material i'll cover
will overlap with information covered
here on the huberman lab podcast and on
various social media posts most of the
information i will cover is going to be
distinct from information covered on the
podcast or elsewhere so once again it's
seattle on may 17th portland on may 18th
you can access tickets by going to
hubermannlab.com
tour and i hope to see you there before
we begin i'd like to emphasize that this
podcast is separate from my teaching and
research roles at stanford it is however
part of my desire and effort to bring
zero cost to consumer information about
science and science-related tools to the
general public in keeping with that
theme i'd like to thank the sponsors of
today's podcast our first sponsor is
athletic greens also called ag1 i
started taking ag-1 way back in 2012 so
i'm delighted that they're sponsoring
the podcast the reason i started taking
ag-1 and the reason i still take ag-1
once or twice a day is that it covers my
foundational vitamin mineral and
probiotic needs it also has adaptogens
and things like zinc for immune system
function but the probiotics are one of
the key features in there i've done
several podcasts on the gut microbiome
which are these trillions of microbiota
that live in our digestive tract and
that are crucial for our immune system
brain function and so on
one way to enhance our gut microbiome to
ensure that it's healthy is to make sure
that we get the correct probiotics and
athletic greens has the correct
prebiotics and probiotics that ensure a
healthy gut microbiome if you'd like to
try athletic greens you can go to
athletic greens.com huberman to claim a
special offer they'll give you five free
travel packs that make it very easy to
mix up athletic greens while you're on
the road so in the car and on the plane
i should mention that athletic greens is
delicious i love the way it tastes i mix
mine with some water and a little bit of
lemon or lime juice this special offer
is the five free travel packs plus a
year's supply of vitamin d3k2 vitamin d3
has been shown to be important for a
tremendous number of biological
functions many of us who get sunlight
get enough vitamin d3 many of us even if
we do get sunlight do not get enough
vitamin d3 so the year supply of vitamin
d3 also has k2 which is important for
cardiovascular function for calcium
regulation again go to athletic
greens.com huberman to get the five free
travel packs and the year supply of
vitamin d3 k2 today's episode is also
brought to us by thesis thesis makes
custom nootropics
nootropic is a smart drug and personally
i'm not a big fan of the concept of a
smart drug at least not the way that
most people talk about smart drugs or
nootropics for the following reason
being smart involves various things
there is creativity there's focus
there's task switching and so on and
each one of those involves different
operations in the brain different neural
circuits different neurochemicals have
to be deployed in order for us to for
instance be very focused or for us to be
very creative or for us to be able to
switch tasks easily
thesis understands this and for that
reason they've developed custom
nootropics that are aimed at getting
your brain and body into particular
states for particular types of
work or physical activity in order to
accomplish that they've created unique
blends of high quality ingredients and
each of those blends is designed to get
your brain and body into a particular
mode such as focus clarity or motivation
i've been using thesis nootropics for
over six months now and i have to say
it's been a total game changer and very
unique from the experience of using sort
of what i call catch-all nootropics so
with thesis it's really directed toward
particular brain body states i should
also mention that they tailor those
custom blends to you so by taking a quiz
on their site they will tailor the blend
to you and your specific needs and the
things you don't want so if you want to
try your own personalized nootropic
starter kit you can go online to
takethesis.com huberman you'll take a
three-minute quiz and thesis will send
you four different formulas to try in
your first month and then based on the
outcomes with those they can update your
formulations for you that's
takethesis.com huberman and use the code
huberman at checkout to get 10 off your
first box today's episode is also
brought to us by element element is a
properly balanced electrolyte drink that
has no sugar
when we get our electrolytes in the
proper ratios the cells of our brain and
body can function optimally many people
are surprised to find that when they
increase their sodium intake provided
that it is in proper balance with
potassium and magnesium they can think
more clearly they recover from exercise
better and they have more energy there
is no surprise as to how that all works
however every cell of your body requires
the electrolytes to function and in
particular the neurons of your brain and
body require sodium in order to function
so while people with pre-hypertension
and hypertension definitely need to be
careful about increasing their sodium
intake many people do well to increase
their sodium intake again provided it's
in the proper balance with potassium
magnesium element provides that proper
balance if you'd like to try element you
can go to drinkelement that's lmnt.com
huberman to claim a free element sample
pack you only cover the cost of shipping
again that's drink element
lmnt.com huberman to claim a free sample
pack okay let's talk about light first i
want to talk about the physics of light
and i promise to make that very clear
even if you don't have a background in
physics and then i want to talk about
the biology of light meaning how light
is converted into signals that your
brain and body can use to impact things
like organ health or disease or how you
can use light in order to repair
particular organs like your skin your
eyes your brain etc the physics of light
can be made very simple by just
illustrating a few key bullet points the
first bullet point is that light is
electromagnetic energy
if the word electromagnetic feels
daunting to you well then just discard
that and just think of light as energy
and think of energy as something that
can impact other things in its
environment
now the way to
imagine light or to conceptualize light
as energy is that all around you light
is traveling in these little wavelengths
and the reason for those of you that are
watching i'm making a little wavy motion
with my hand is that's actually the way
that light energy moves in little waves
just like sound waves are coming at you
and impinging on your ears if you can
hear me talking right now that is
happening those are sound waves meaning
the movement of air particles out there
impacting your eardrum well light energy
is just little bits of electromagnetic
energy traveling through your
environment all the time in these little
waves and impinging on your brain and
body and eyes etc and as i mentioned
before energy can change the way that
other things behave it can cause
reactions in cells of your body it can
cause reactions in fruit for instance
right you see a piece of fruit and it's
not ripe but it gets a lot of sunlight
and it ripens that's because the
electromagnetic energy of sunlight
had an impact on that plant or that tree
or even on the fruit directly as a
parallel example of energy and its
ability to impact other things
we are all familiar with food and the
fact that food has calories
calorie is a measure of energy it has
everything to do with how much heat is
generated when you burn a particular
article of food believe it or not and it
turns out that how hot a given article
of food burns
gives you a sense of how much energy it
can provide your body in terms of your
body's ability to store or use that
energy so again think of light as
electromagnetic energy but really put
that word energy into capital letters
embed that in your mind going forward
and you'll understand most of the first
bullet point
of what light is in terms of the physics
of light now the second thing that you
need to understand about the physics of
light is that light has many different
wavelengths and the simplest way to
conceptualize this is to imagine that
cover of that pink floyd album where
there's a prism you have a white beam of
light going into that prism and then the
prism splits that beam of light into
what looks like a rainbow so you've got
your reds your orange your greens your
blues your purples etc
anytime we have light in our environment
that is so-called white light it
includes all those wavelengths but
sunlight and other forms of light also
have
other wavelengths of light that we can't
see so when we think about the rainbow
that's just the visible spectrum of
light
there are also wavelengths of light that
are not visible to us but that are
visible to some other animals and that
can still impact
your brain and body because there is
still energy at those wavelengths
give a few examples of this
humans are not a species that can see
into the infrared
realm of the spectrum
a pit viper
meaning a snake that has infrared
sensors however can sense in the
infrared so if you were to walk through
a jungle and there's a pit viper there
it sees you as a cloud of heat emission
because your body is emitting infrared
energy all the time you're casting off
infrared energy
the snake can see it you can't if you
were to put on a particular set of
goggles that were infrared goggles well
then you would be able to see the heat
emissions of any organism human or
otherwise that could emit infrared
energy
let's take the opposite end of the
spectrum we are familiar with seeing
things that are blue or green or very
pale blue but
as we say below that meaning even
shorter wavelength light is out there
ultraviolet light is a really good
example of light energy that's coming
from the sun and is in our environment
is being reflected off surfaces all the
time
we don't see it and yet if it's very
bright outside that ultraviolet light
can burn our skin as you'll learn in
today's episode ultraviolet light
can also positively impact us
in fact i will describe a particular set
of new results that show that
ultraviolet light viewed for just a few
minutes each day or landing on the skin
for just a few minutes each day can
actually offset a lot of pain it
actually has the ability to reduce the
amount of pain sensed by your body and
we now understand the specific circuits
in the brain and body that allow that to
happen i'll talk about that and the
related protocols a little bit later so
the important thing to understand about
the physics of light is that there's
energy at all these different
wavelengths we only see some of those
wavelengths which basically is to say
that light impacts us at many different
levels
and the so-called levels that i'm
referring to are the different
wavelengths of light and you're welcome
to think of the different wavelengths of
light as different colors but do
understand that there are truly colors
of light that you and i can't see and
yet that have powerful impact on your
brain and body now the third bullet
point to understand about the physics of
light is that different wavelengths of
light because of the way that their wave
travels can
penetrate tissues to different depths
this is very very important today we're
going to talk a lot about red light
therapies and near infrared light
therapies
those are so-called longer wavelengths
longer wavelengths just think of a
bigger
longer wave right a bigger curve as
opposed to short wavelength light which
is going to be shorter right a short
wavelength light would be something like
blue or green light or ultraviolet light
blue green and ultraviolet light because
it's short wavelength light doesn't tend
to penetrate tissues very easily
it has to do with the way that the
physics of light interacts with the
physical properties of your skin and
other tissues of your body but basically
if you were to shine uv light onto your
arm for instance it could impact the
skin on the surface of the arm and maybe
some of the cells just beneath the top
layer of skin but it wouldn't penetrate
much deeper
long wavelength light like red light and
near infrared light has this amazing
ability to penetrate through tissues
including your skin and so if we were to
shine red light or near infrared light
onto your arm
it would pass through that top layer of
skin it might impact it a little bit but
it could penetrate deeper into your skin
not just to the skin layers but maybe
even down to the bone maybe even down to
the bone marrow and for many people this
would be hard to conceptualize you think
well wait i've got a skin there doesn't
the light just bounce off and the answer
is no because of the way that long
wavelength light
interacts with the absorbance properties
of your skin absorbance properties are
just the way that the skin takes light
energy and converts it into a different
form of energy and your skin is not able
to take long wavelength light like red
light and near-infrared light and absorb
it but the tissues deeper in your body
can so if you shine red light or
near-infrared light onto the surface of
your skin you'll see a red glow there as
a reflectance on the surface of your
skin but a lot of the photon energy the
light energy in those longer wavelengths
is indeed passing through those top
layers of skin into the deeper layers of
skin and can even make it into the deep
layers of your arm and as we start to
transition from the physics of light to
the biological impacts of light
just understanding that the different
wavelengths of light impact our tissues
at different levels literally at
different depths will help you better
understand how light of different colors
of different intensities and
how long you're exposed to those colors
and intensity of light can change the
way that the cells and the organs of
your body work and if it didn't sound
weird enough that you can pass light
through particular tissues and have them
land and be absorbed at tissues deeper
in your body
well it turns out that different
wavelengths of light are also best
absorbed by particular so-called
organelles within your cells what are
organelles organelles are the different
compartments and different
functions within a given cell so for
instance your mitochondria which are
responsible for generating atp and
energy in your cells
those exist at a particular
depth at a particular location within a
cell they're not all at the cell surface
they sit somewhat deeper in the cell the
nucleus of your individual cells
contains dna and that sits at a
particular depth or location within your
cell
different wavelengths of light not only
can penetrate down into different
tissues and into different cells of your
body
but they can also penetrate and access
particular organelles meaning
mitochondria or the nucleus or the
different aspects of your cells that are
responsible for different functions
this is exquisitely important and it's
exquisitely powerful because as you'll
learn today particular wavelengths of
light can be used to stimulate the
function of particular organelles within
particular cells within particular
organs of your body
i can think of no other form of energy
not sound
not chemical energy so not drugs
not
food
not
touch
no form of energy that can target the
particular locations in our cells
in our organelles in our organs and in
our body to the extent that light can in
other words if you had to imagine a real
world surgical tool by which to modulate
our biology
light would be the sharpest and the most
precise of those tools now let's talk
about how light is converted into
biological signals there are several
ways in which that is accomplished but
the fundamental thing to understand
is this notion of absorption of light
energy
certain
pigments or colors
in the
thing that is receiving the light energy
meaning the thing that the light energy
lands on
are going to absorb particular
wavelengths of light now i promise you
that you already intuitively know how
this works
for instance if you were to sit outside
on a very bright sunny day and you had a
table in front of you that was metal
you might find it hard to look down at
that metal table because it's reflecting
a lot of light of particular wavelengths
if that table were pitch black however
it wouldn't reflect quite as much
and you would be able to comfortably
look at it
if that table were red it might be
somewhere in between if that table were
green
it would be also somewhere in between
but let's say it were very light blue
well then it might reflect almost as
much as a table that were just metal or
a white
table surface so the absorbance
properties of a given surface will
determine whether or not light energy
goes and
stays at that location and has an impact
on that location or whether or not it
bounces off
every biological function of light has
to do with the absorbance or the
reflectance of light or light passing
through that particular
thing meaning that particular cell or
compartment within a cell
i'd like to make it clear how this works
by using the three primary examples of
how you take light in your environment
and convert it into biological events
we have photoreceptors in the back of
our eyes these photoreceptors come in
two major types the so-called rods and
the cones the rods are very elongated
they look like rods and the cones look
like little triangles
rods and cones
have within them
photo pigment they have dark stuff
that's stacked up in little layers
rods absorb light of essentially any
wavelength there's some variation to
that but let's just say it
rods don't care about the different
colors of light they will absorb light
energy photon energy if it's red if it's
green if it's blue if it's yellow
doesn't matter as long as that light is
bright enough and it turns out that rods
are very very sensitive they can detect
very very small numbers of photons and
rods are essentially what you use to see
in very low light conditions we'll
return more to vision later the cones
come in three major varieties at least
for most people who aren't colorblind
you have so-called red cones green cones
and blue cones but they're not really
red green and blue in the back your eye
they are cones that either absorb long
wavelength light red
that absorb medium wavelength light
green or short wavelength light blue
the reason that they can absorb
different wavelengths of light is they
have different photo pigments so much as
the example i gave before where you have
different tables
outside in the sunny environment and
some are reflecting light more than
others others are absorbing light more
than others
well so too the photoreceptors meaning
the cones are absorbing light of
different wavelengths to different
extents and in an
absolutely incredible way your brain is
actually able to take that information
and create this perception that we have
of color but that's another story
altogether that we'll just touch on a
little bit more later but that if you
want to learn all about you can go to
our episode on vision
so that's photoreceptors in the back of
your eye absorbing light of different
wavelengths rods and cones
the other place of course where light
can impact our body is on our surface on
our skin
and skin has pigment too we call that
pigment melanin
we have within our skin multiple cell
types but in the top layer of skin which
is called the epidermis
we have keratinocytes
and we have melanocytes and the
melanocytes are the cells that create
pigmentation of the skin and of course
there is wide variation in the degree to
which there's pigmentation of the skin
which has to do with genetics also has
to do with where you were born and
raised how much light exposure you have
throughout the year right so people
toward the equator tend to have more
melanocyte activity than people who are
located at the north pole and of course
people live at different locations
throughout the earth regardless of their
genetic background or where they were
born and so
as you all know with light exposure
those melanocytes will turn on genetic
programs and other biological programs
that lead to enhanced pigmentation in
the skin which we call tanning
the way they do that is by absorbing uv
light specifically
so with melanocytes we have a very
specific example of how a pigment
absorbs light of a particular length in
this case ultraviolet short wavelength
light which in turn
creates a set of biological signals
within those cells that in turn creates
changes in our skin pigmentation so we
have photoreceptors we have melanocytes
and the third example i'd like to
provide is that of every cell of your
body and what i mean by that is that
every cell of your body meaning a cell
that is part of your bone tissue or your
bone marrow or heart tissue or liver or
spleen
if light can access those cells it will
change the way that those cells function
for better or for worse
for many organs within our body that
reside deep
to our skin
light never arrives at those cells a
really good example of this that we'll
touch on later is the spleen
unless you have massive damage to your
body surface unless you literally have a
hole in your body light will never land
directly on your spleen
but the spleen still responds to light
information through indirect pathways
and those indirect pathways arise
through light arriving on the skin and
light arriving on the eyes so a key
principle that i'm going to return to
again and again today is that
the ways in which light can impact the
biology of your organelles your cells
your organs and the tissues and indeed
your whole body can either be direct so
for instance light onto your skin
impacting skin or light onto your
photoreceptors impacting the
photoreceptors of your eye or it can be
indirect it can be light arriving on
your photoreceptors the photoreceptors
then informing another cell type which
informs another cell type which then
relays a signal in kind of a bucket
brigade manner off to the spleen and
says to the spleen hey
there's a lot of uv light out here we're
actually under stress in fact there's so
much uv light that you need to activate
an immune
program to protect the skin and in
response to that the spleen can deploy
certain signals in certain cell types to
go out and start repairing skin that's
being damaged by uv light so we have
direct signals and we have indirect
signals
but
in every case it starts with light of
particular wavelengths
being absorbed by particular pigments or
properties of the surfaces that those
light waves land on
and as you recall from our discussion
about the physics of light remember it's
not just about light impinging on the
surface of your body light can actually
penetrate deep to the skin
and access at least certain tissues and
cells of your body
even though you can't see those
wavelengths of light they are getting
into you all the time so perhaps the
best way to
wrap this discussion about the physics
and the biology of light with a bit of a
bow
is to think about light as a transducer
meaning a communicator of what's going
on in the environment around you and
that some of those signals are arriving
at the surface and impacting the surface
of your body
but many of those signals are being
taken by cells at the surface of your
body meaning your melanocytes in your
skin and the photoreceptors of your eyes
and then being passed off as a set of
instructions to the other organs and
tissues of your body life can impact our
biology in it very fast moderately fast
and slow ways
but even the slow ways in which light
can impact our biology can be very
powerful and very long lasting
just as a quick example of the rapid
effects of light on our biology
if you were to go from a room that is
dimly lit or dark into a very brightly
lit room
you would immediately feel very alert
you might say no that's not true
sometimes i wake up and it's dark and i
kind of stumble out and it's lighter out
in the next room and it takes me a while
to wake up ah but if we were to move you
from a room that was very dark to very
bright a signal
conveyed from your eyes to an area of
your brain stem called the locus
ceruleus
would cause the release of adrenaline
similar to the release of adrenaline if
you were to be dropped into very very
cold water all of a sudden just an
immediate wake-up signal to your brain
and body so that's an example of a rapid
effect of light on your biology not a
very typical one but nonetheless one
that has a hardwired biological
mechanism
at the other end of the spectrum
are what we call slow integrating
effects of light on our biology
so what i mean by that are ways in which
your body is taking information about
light in the environment not in the sort
of snapshot acute sense but averaging
the amount of light in your environment
and that average light information is
changing the way that your biology works
but even though this is a slow process
as i mentioned before it's a very
powerful one
the primary example of this
are so-called circannual rhythms
circannual rhythms are literally a
calendar that exists within your body
that uses not numbers but amounts of
hormone that are released into your
brain and body each day and each night
as a way of knowing where you are in the
365 day calendar year
now that might seem kind of crazy but
it's not crazy the earth travels around
the sun once every 365 days
and depending on where you are
on the earth where you live
you are going to get more or less light
each day on average depending on the
time of year so
if you're in the northern hemisphere in
the winter months days are shorter
nights are longer
in the summer months days are longer
nights are shorter and of course things
change whether or not you're in the
northern hemisphere or the southern
hemisphere
but nonetheless
in short days
you have more darkness that's obvious
and if you understand that light
arriving on the eyes
is absorbed by a particular cell type
called the intrinsically photosensitive
ganglion cell it's just a name you don't
need to know the name but if you want
it's the so-called intrinsically
photosensitive ganglion cell also called
the melanopsin cell because it contains
an opsin a photopigment
that absorbs
short wavelength light
that arrives through sunlight those
cells communicate to particular stations
in the brain that in turn connect to
your so-called pineal gland which is
this little pea-sized gland in the
middle of your brain that releases a
hormone called melatonin and the only
thing you need to know is that light
activates these particular cells the
intrinsically photosensitive melanopsin
cells which in turn shuts down the
production of melatonin from the pineal
gland
if you think about this in terms of the
travel of the earth around the sun
across the year
what it means is that in short days
because there's very little light on
average landing on these cells
the duration of melatonin release will
be much longer because as i mentioned
before
light inhibits it shuts down melatonin
whereas in the summer months
much more light on average will land on
your eyes right because days are longer
even if you're spending more time
indoors on average you're going to get
more
light to activate these cells and
because light
shuts down melatonin production what
you'll find is that the duration of
melatonin release from the pineal is
much shorter
so melatonin is a transducer it's a
communicator of how much light on
average is in your physical environment
what this means is
for people living in the northern
hemisphere you're getting more melatonin
release in the winter months than you
are in the summer months
so you have a calendar system
that is based in a hormone and that
hormone is using light in order to
determine where you are in that journey
around the sun
now this is beautiful at least to me
it's beautiful because what it means is
that the environment around us is
converted into a signal that changes the
environment within us
that signal is melatonin and melatonin
is well known for its role in making us
sleepy each night and allowing us to
fall asleep
many of you have probably heard before i
am not a big fan of melatonin
supplementation for a number of reasons
but just as a quick aside
the levels of melatonin that are in most
supplements are far too high to really
be considered physiological they are
indeed super physiological in most cases
and melatonin can have a number of
different effects not just related to
sleep but
that's supplemented melatonin here i'm
talking about our natural production and
release of melatonin according to where
we are in the 365 day calendar year
endogenous melatonin meaning the
melatonin that we make within our bodies
naturally not melatonin that's
supplemented
has two general categories of
effects
the first set of effects are so called
regulatory effects and the others are
protective effects the regulatory
effects are for instance that melatonin
can positively impact bone mass
so melatonin can for instance turn on
the production of osteoblasts which are
essentially stem cells that make more
bone
for us that make our bones stronger and
that can replace damaged aspects of our
bone
melatonin is also involved in maturation
of the gonads during puberty the ovaries
and the testes although there the
effects of melatonin tend to be
suppressive on maturation of the ovaries
and testes meaning high levels of
melatonin tend to reduce testicle volume
and
reduce certain functions within the
testes including sperm production and
testosterone production and within the
ovaries
melatonin can suppress the maturation of
eggs etc now i don't want anyone to get
scared if you've been taking melatonin
most the effects of melatonin on those
functions are reversible but i should
point out that one of the reasons why
children don't go into puberty until a
particular age is that young children
tend to have chronically high endogenous
melatonin and that is healthy to keep
them out of puberty until
it's the right time for puberty to
happen so melatonin can increase bone
mass but reduces gonad mass so to speak
it's going to have varying effects
depending on the
ratios and levels of other hormones and
other biological events in the body but
as you can see melatonin has these
powerful regulatory effects on other
tissues i should also mention that
melatonin is a powerful modulator of
placental development so for anyone
that's pregnant if you're considering
melatonin supplementation please please
please talk to your ob gyn talk to your
other doctor as well you want to be very
very cautious because of the powerful
effects that melatonin can have on the
developing fetus and placenta
for people that are not pregnant in fact
all people melatonin has a powerful
effect on the central nervous system as
a whole your brain and spinal cord are
the major components of your central
nervous system and melatonin because
it's associated with darkness
which is just another way of saying that
light suppresses melatonin melatonin is
thereby associated with the dark phase
of each 24-hour cycle
it can have a number of different
effects
in terms of waking up or making our body
feel more sleepy and it does that by way
of impacting cells within our nervous
system literally turning on certain
brain areas turning off other brain
areas and it does that through a whole
cascade of biological mechanisms a bit
too detailed to get into today so
melatonin is regulating how awake or
asleep we are it tends to make us more
asleep incidentally
it's regulating our timing of puberty
and it's regulating how our gonads the
testes and ovaries function even in
adulthood to some extent and it's
regulating bone mass
as i mentioned before melatonin also has
protective effects it can activate our
immune system it is among the most
potent antioxidants
so it is known to have certain
anti-cancer properties and things of
that sort which is not to say that you
simply want more melatonin i think a lot
of people get misled when they hear
something like melatonin has anti-cancer
properties that doesn't mean that just
cranking up the levels of melatonin by
supplementing it
or by spending time in darkness and not
getting any light which would of course
inhibit melatonin is going to be
beneficial for combating cancer that's
not the way it works
it is actually the rise and fall of
melatonin every 24 hour cycle and the
changes in the duration of that
melatonin signal throughout the seasons
that has these anti-cancer and
antioxidant effects so when we think
about light impacting our biology the
reason i bring up melatonin as the
primary example of that is a because
melatonin impacts so many important
functions within our brain and body but
also because
hormones in general not always but in
general are responsible for these slow
modulatory effects on our biology and so
i'm using this as an example of how
light throughout the year is changing
the way that your the different cells
and tissues and organs of your body are
working and that melatonin is the
transducer of that signal so at this
point we can say light powerfully
modulates melatonin meaning it shuts
down melatonin melatonin is both
beneficial for certain tissues and
suppressive for other tissues and
functions what should we do with this
information well
it's very well established now that one
of the best things that we can all do is
to get the proper amount of sunlight
each day and by proper i mean
appropriate for that time of year so in
the summer months where the days are
longer and nights are shorter we would
all do well to get more sunlight in our
eyes and again it's going to be to our
eyes because as you recall
the pineal sits deep in the brain and
light can't access the pineal directly
at least not in humans so
in order to get light information to the
pineal and thereby get the proper levels
of melatonin
according to the time of year we should
all try and get outside as much as
possible during the long days of summer
and spring and in the winter months it
makes sense to spend more time indoors
for those of you that suffer from
seasonal affective disorder which is a
seasonal depression or feel low during
the fall and winter months there are
ways to offset this we did an entire
episode on mood and circadian rhythms
where we described this so it does make
sense for some people to get more bright
light in their eyes early in the morning
and throughout the day during the winter
months as well but nonetheless
changes in melatonin meaning changes in
the duration of melatonin release across
the year are normal and healthy so
provided that you're not suffering from
depression it's going to be healthy to
somewhat modulate your amount of indoor
and outdoor time across the year
the other thing to understand is this
very firmly established fact which is
light powerfully inhibits melatonin
if you wake up in the middle of the
night and you go into the bathroom and
you flip on the lights and those are
very bright overhead fluorescent lights
your melatonin levels which would
ordinarily be quite high in the middle
of the night because you've been eyes
closed in the dark presumably will
immediately plummet to near zero or zero
we would all do well regardless of time
of year
to not
destroy our melatonin in the middle of
the night in this way so if you need to
get up in the middle of the night and
use the restroom which is a perfectly
normal behavior for many people
use the minimum amount of light required
in order to
safely move through the environment that
you need to move through
melatonin needs to come on early in the
night it actually starts rising in the
evening and towards sleep but then as
you close your eyes and you go to sleep
melatonin levels are going to continue
to rise at least for several hours into
the night
again if you get up in the middle of the
night really try hard not to flip on a
lot of bright lights if you do that
every once in a while it's not going to
be a problem but if you're doing that
night after night you are really
disrupting this fundamental signal
that occurs every night regardless of
winter spring summer etc and that is
communicating information about where
your brain and body should be in time
and i know that's a little bit of a
tricky concept but really our body is
not meant to function in the same way
during the winter months as the summer
months there are functions that are
specifically optimal for the shorter
days of winter and there are functions
that are specifically optimal for the
longer days of summer so again
try to avoid bright light exposure to
your eyes in the middle of the night and
for those of you that are doing shift
work what i can say is try and avoid
getting bright light in your eyes in the
middle of your sleep cycle so even if
you're sleeping in the middle of the day
because you have to work at night if you
wake up during that bout of sleep really
try hard to limit the amount of light
which is going to be harder for shift
workers right because they're generally
a lot more lights on and bright lights
outside to you you would want to close
the blinds and limit artificial light
inside
one way to bypass some of the
inhibitory effects of light on melatonin
is to change your physical environment
by for instance dimming the lights
that's one simple way very low cost way
in fact you'll save money by dimming the
lights or turning them off the other is
if you are going to use light using long
wavelength light because as you recall
these intrinsically photosensitive
melanopsin cells within your retina that
convey the signal about
bright light in your environment to
impact melatonin to shut down melatonin
respond to short wavelengths of light so
red light is long wavelength light you
now understand that from our discussion
about the physics of light
and if you were to use amber colored
light or red light and even better dim
amber or dim red light in the middle of
the night well then you would probably
not reduce melatonin at all unless those
red lights and amber lights are very
very bright any light provided it's
bright enough will shut down melatonin
production
one final point about melatonin and this
relates to melatonin supplementation as
well is that now that you understand how
potently melatonin can impact things
like cardiovascular function immune
function anti-cancer properties bone
mass gonad function etc
you can understand why it would make
sense to be cautious about melatonin
supplementation because supplementation
tends to be pretty static it's x number
of milligrams per night whereas
normally endogenously the amount of
melatonin that you're releasing each
night is changing according to time of
year
or if you happen to live in an area
where there isn't much change in day
length across the year so for instance
if you live near the equator well then
your body is accustomed to having
regular amounts of melatonin each night
when you start supplementing melatonin
you start changing the total amount of
melatonin obviously but you're also
changing the normal rhythms in how much
melatonin is being released into your
brain and body across the 365-day
calendar year so while i'm somebody who
readily embraces supplementation in
various forms for things like sleep and
focus etc
when it comes to melatonin i'm extremely
cautious and i think it's also one of
the few examples where a hormone is
available without prescription
over-the-counter you just go into a
pharmacy or drugstore order online this
hormone which is known to have all these
powerful effects so i get very very
concerned when i hear about people
taking melatonin especially at the
levels that are present in most
supplements it's been recognized for a
very long time and in fact there are now
data to support the fact that animals of
all kinds including humans
will seek out mates and engage in mating
behavior more frequently during the long
days of spring and summer that's right
in seasonally breeding animals of course
this is the case but in humans as well
there is more seeking out of mates and
mating behavior in longer day
times of year now you can imagine at
least two mechanisms by which this
occurs
the first mechanism we could easily map
to melatonin and the fact that melatonin
is suppressive to various aspects of the
so-called gonadal axis which is
basically a fancy way of saying that
melatonin inhibits testosterone and
estrogen output from the testes and from
the ovaries i just want to remind people
that both males and females make
testosterone and estrogen although in
different ratios typically in males
versus females and that both
testosterone and estrogen are critical
for the desire to mate and for mating
behavior
there's a broad misconception that
testosterone is involved in mating
behavior and estrogen is involved in
other behaviors but having enough
estrogen is critical for both males and
females in order to maintain the desire
to mate and indeed the ability to mate i
discussed this on the episode on
optimizing testosterone and estrogen so
if you'd like more details on that
please see that episode of the huberman
lab podcast
okay so if melatonin is suppressive to
the so-called gonadolaxis and reduces
overall levels of testosterone and
estrogen in males and females
and the light
inhibits melatonin then when there's
more light then there's less melatonin
and more hormone output from the gonads
and indeed that's how the system works
but that's not the entire story it turns
out that there is a second
so-called parallel pathway meaning a
different biological pathway that
operates in parallel to the light
suppression of melatonin pathway that
provides a basis for longer days
inspiring more desire to mate and more
mating behavior so if we think of the
first pathway involving melatonin as
sort of a break on these reproductive
hormones the second mechanism is more
like an accelerator on those hormones
and yet it still involves light as i'm
about to tell you in animals such as
mice but also in humans
exposure to light in particular uv blue
light so short wavelengths of light
can trigger increases in testosterone
and estrogen and the desire to mate now
what's especially important about this
accelerator on the desire to mate and
mating behavior and hormones is that it
is driven by exposure to light
but it is not the exposure of light to
the eyes it turns out that it is the
exposure of your skin to particular
wavelengths of light that is triggering
increases in the hormones testosterone
and estrogen leading to increased desire
to mate as it turns out your skin
which most of us just think of as a way
to protect the organs of our body or
something to hang clothes on or
ornaments on if you're somebody who has
earrings and so forth
your skin is actually an endocrine organ
meaning it is a hormone producing and
hormone influencing organ
i promise what i'm about to tell you
next will forever change the way that
you think about your skin and light and
the desire to mate and indeed even
mating behavior
i think the results are best understood
by simply going through the primary data
meaning the actual research on this
topic and to do so i'm going to review a
recent paper that was published in the
journal cell reports cell press journal
excellent journal this is a paper that
came out in 2021
entitled skin exposure to uvb light
induces a skin brain gonad axis and
sexual behavior and i want to emphasize
that this was a paper that focused on
mice in order to address specific
mechanisms because in mice you can
so-called knockout particular genes you
can remove particular genes to
understand mechanism you just can't do
that in humans in any kind of controlled
way at least not at this point in time
and this study also explores humans and
looked at human subjects both men and
women
the basic finding of this study was that
when mice or humans were exposed to uvb
meaning ultraviolet blue light so short
wavelength light of the sort that comes
through in sunshine but is also
available through various artificial
sources
if they
received enough exposure of that light
to their skin
there were increases in
testosterone that were observed within a
very brief period of time also increases
in the hormone estrogen and i should
point out that the proper ratios of
estrogen and testosterone were
maintained in both males and females at
least as far as these data indicate
and
mice tended to seek out mating more and
mate more there were also increases in
gonadal weight
literally increases in testy size and in
ovarian size when mice were exposed to
this uvb light
past a certain threshold now as i
mentioned before the study also looked
at humans they did not look at testes
size or ovarian size in the human
subjects however because they are humans
they did
address the psychology of these human
beings and address whether or not they
had increases in for instance
aggressiveness or impassionate feelings
and how their perception of other people
changed when they were getting a lot of
uvb
light exposure to the skin so before i
get into some of the more important
details of the study and how it was done
and how you can leverage this
information for yourself if you desire
i just want to highlight some of the
basic findings overall
uvb exposure increased these so-called
sex steroid levels in mice and humans
the sex storied hormones
when we say steroids we don't mean
anabolic steroids taken exogenously i
think when people hear the word steroids
they always think steroid abuse or use
rather steroid hormones such as
testosterone and estrogen went up when
mice or humans
had a lot of uvb exposure to their skin
second of all uvb light exposure to the
skin
enhanced female attractiveness so the
perceived attractiveness of females by
males and increase the receptiveness or
the desire to mate
in both sexes uvb light exposure also
changed various aspects of female
biology related to fertility in
particular follicle growth
follicle and egg maturation are
well-known indices of fertility and of
course correlate with the menstrual
cycle in adult humans and is related
overall to the propensity to become
pregnant
uvb light exposure enhanced maturation
of the follicle which just meant that
more healthy eggs were being produced
these are impressive effects first of
all they looked at a large number of
variables in the study and the fact that
they looked at mice and humans is
terrific i think that oftentimes we find
it hard to translate data from mice to
humans so the fact that they looked at
both in parallel
is
wonderful in the mice and in the humans
they
established a protocol that essentially
involved
exposing the skin to uv light that was
equivalent to about 20 to 30 minutes of
midday sun exposure now of course where
you live in the world will dictate
whether or not that midday sun is very
very bright and intense or is less
bright maybe there's cloud cover etc but
since imagine that most people are
interested in
ways to increase testosterone and or
estrogen in humans and are not so much
interested in increasing testosterone in
mice i'm going to just review what they
did in the human population or the human
subjects
what they did is they had people first
of all establish a baseline and the way
they establish a baseline was a little
bit unusual but will make perfect sense
to you they had people wear long sleeves
and essentially cover up and avoid
sunlight for a few days so they could
measure their baseline hormones in the
absence of getting a lot of uvb light
exposure from the sun or from other
sources now of course these people
had access to artificial lights but as
i've pointed out on this podcast before
it's pretty unusual that you'll get
enough uvb exposure from artificial
lights throughout the day and in the
morning you need a lot of uvb exposure
or we should be getting a lot of uvb
exposure to our eyes and to our face
into our skin throughout the day
provided we're not getting sunburned
this is actually a healthy thing for
mood and for energy throughout the day
it's only at night basically between the
hours of about 10 pm and 4 am that even
a tiny bit of uvb exposure from
artificial sources can mess us up in
terms of our sleep and our energy levels
and so on and that's because of the
potent effect of uvb on suppressing
melatonin so the point here is that they
establish a baseline whereby people were
getting some artificial light exposure
throughout the day but they weren't
getting outside a lot they weren't
getting a lot of sunlight and then they
had people receive a dose
of uvb light exposure
that was about 20 to 30 minutes
outdoors they had people wear short
sleeves no hat no sunglasses some people
wore sleeveless shirts they encouraged
people to wear shorts so they were
indeed wearing clothing
they were not naked and they were
wearing clothing that was
culturally and situationally appropriate
at least for the part of the world where
the study was done and they had people
do that two or three times a week so in
terms of a protocol that you might
export from this study basically getting
outside for about 30 minutes two or
three times a week in a minimum of
clothing and yet still uh wearing enough
clothing that is culturally appropriate
they were outside they weren't
sunbathing flipping over on their back
in front they were just moving about
doing things they could read they could
talk they could go about other
activities
but they weren't wearing a broad brim
hat or a hat of any kind just getting a
lot of sun exposure to their skin
they did this for a
total of 10 to 12 uvb treatments so this
took several weeks right it took about a
month if you think about it two or three
times per week for a total of 10 to 12
uvb treatments
these treatments of course are just
being outside in the sun
and then they measured hormones and they
measure the psychology of these male and
female adult subjects let's first look
at the psychological changes that these
human subjects experienced after getting
10 to 12 of these uvb light exposure
outdoor and sunlight type treatments
they did this by collecting blood
samples throughout the study
and they saw significant increases in
the hormones beta estradiol which is one
of the major forms of estrogen
progesterone another important steroid
hormone and testosterone in both men and
women now an important point is that the
testosterone increases were
significantly higher
in men that happened to originate from
countries that had low uv exposure
compared to individuals from countries
with high uv exposure
now this ought to make sense if we
understand a little bit about how the
skin functions as an endocrine organ
many of you have probably heard of
vitamin d3 which is a vitamin that we
all make
many people supplement it as well if
they need additional vitamin d3
we all require sunlight in order to
allow vitamin d3 to be synthesized and
perform its roles in the body and it
turns out that people who have darker
skin actually need more vitamin d3 and
or more sunlight exposure in order to
activate that d3 pathway then do people
with paler skin
and this should make sense to all of you
given what you now understand about
melanocytes that cell type that we
discussed earlier because melanocytes
have pigment within them
and if you have darker skin it means
that you have more melanocytes or that
you have melanocytes that are more
efficient at creating pigment
and as a consequence
the light that lands on your skin will
be absorbed by those melanocytes and
less of it is able to impact the d3
pathway whereas if you have pale skin
more of the light that lands on your
skin can trigger the synthesis and
assist the actions of vitamin d3
similarly in this study they found that
people who had paler skin and or who
originated from countries where they had
less uvb light exposure across the year
had greater meaning more significant
increases in testosterone overall than
did people who already were getting a
lot of ubb exposure this led them to
explore so-called seasonal changes in
testosterone that occurred normally in
the absence of any light exposure
treatment so up until now i've been
talking about the aspects of this study
involving people getting outside for
about 20 to 30 minutes per day in
sunlight in a minimum of clothing there
was an increase in testosterone observed
in both men and women the increases in
testosterone were greater for people
that had paler skin than darker skin so
the data i'm about to describe also come
from this same paper but do not involve
20 to 30 minute daily sun exposure
protocols it's simply addressing whether
or not testosterone levels change as a
function of time of year
they measure testosterone across the
12-month calendar
this study was done on subjects living
in the northern hemisphere for the
entire year and so
in the months of january february and
march of course the
length of days is shortest and the
length of nights is longest and of
course in the spring and summer months
june july august september and so on the
days are much longer and the nights are
shorter and what they observed was very
obvious
they observed that
testosterone levels were lowest in the
winter months and were highest in the
months of june july august and september
now these are very important data at
least to my knowledge these are the
first data systematically exploring the
levels of sex droid hormones in humans
as a function of time of year and
thereby as a function of how much
sunlight exposure they're getting and
what's remarkable about these data is
that they map very well to the data and
mice and the other data in this paper on
humans which
illustrate that if you're getting more
uvb exposure your testosterone levels
are higher this study went a step
further and explored whether or not the
amount of sunlight exposure that one is
getting to their skin influences their
psychology in terms of whether or not
they have increased desire to mate and
so on it's well known that sunlight
exposure to the eyes can increase mood
and i talked about this in the podcast
episode with my guest dr samar hatar
who's the director of the chronobiology
unit at the national institutes of
mental health and samuer's
recommendation is that people get as
much bright light exposure as they
safely can in the morning and throughout
the day for sake of both sleep and
energy but also for enhancing mood and
regulating appetite in this study
it was found that both
males and females had higher levels of
romantic passion after getting the uv
treatment
in fact some of them reported increases
in romantic passion from just one or two
of these uv treatments so they didn't
have to go through all 10 or 12 in order
to get a statistically significant
increase in passion now when we talk
about passion as the authors of this
paper acknowledge there's really two
forms there is emotional and sexual and
they parse this pretty finely i don't
want to go into all the details and we
can provide a reference and link to this
study if you'd like to look at those
details but what they found was that
women receiving this uvb light exposure
focused more on increases in physical
arousal and sexual passion whereas the
men actually scored higher on the
cognitive dimensions of passion such as
obsessive thoughts about their partner
and so on regardless both males and
females
experienced and reported a increase in
sexual passion and desire to mate and we
now know there were increases in
testosterone and estrogen which of
course could be driving the
psychological changes although i'm sure
that those interact in both directions
meaning
the hormones no doubt affect psychology
and no doubt the psychology these
changes and passionate feelings no doubt
also increased or changed the hormone
levels as well and i want to
re-emphasize that there was a component
of the study that had no deliberate
daylight sunlight exposure for 20 or 30
minutes but rather just looked at
hormone levels throughout the year and
found that the increase in day length
correlated with increases in
testosterone and sexual passion now my
opinion this is a very noteworthy study
because it really illustrates that
sunlight and day length can impact the
melatonin pathway and thereby take the
foot off the break so to speak on
testosterone estrogen and the desire to
mate it also emphasizes that sunlight
uvb light can directly trigger hormone
pathways
and desire to mate and mating behavior
now this study went a step further in
defining the precise mechanism by which
light can impact all these hormones and
this desire to mate
and here understanding the mechanism is
key if you want to export a particular
protocol or tool that you might apply
we talked earlier about how uvb light
exposure to the eyes triggers activation
of these particular neurons within the
eye and then with centers deeper in the
brain and eventually the pineal gland to
suppress the output of melatonin and
thereby to allow testosterone and
estrogen to exist at higher levels
because
melatonin can inhibit testosterone and
estrogen
in this study they were able to very
clearly establish that it is sunlight
exposure to our skin that is causing
these hormone increases that they
observed in mice and humans and the way
they did that
was to use the so-called knockout
technology the ability to remove
specific genes within specific tissues
of the body
and what they found is that uvb light
meaning sunlight exposed
skin
up regulated meaning increase the
activity of something called p53 which
is involved in the maturation of cells
and various aspects of cellular function
and the cells they were focused on were
the keratinocytes which you are now
familiar with from our earlier
discussion about the fact that the
epidermis of your skin contains mainly
keratinocytes and melanocytes
sunlight exposure increased p53 activity
in the skin
and p53 activity was required for the
downstream increases in ovarian size in
testicular size in
testosterone increases in the estrogen
increases and the various other changes
that they observed at the physiological
level when animals or humans were
exposed to sunlight so these data are
important because what they mean is that
not only is it important that we get
sunlight exposure early in the day and
throughout the day to our eyes at least
as much as as safely possible but that
we also need to get uvb sunlight
exposure onto our skin if we want to
activate this p53 pathway in
keratinocytes
and the testosterone and estrogen
increases that are downstream of that
p53 pathway so even though the gene
knockout studies were done on mice
they clearly show that if you remove p53
from the skin
that these effects simply do not occur
so in terms of thinking about a protocol
to increase testosterone and estrogen
mood and feelings of passion
the idea is that you would want to get
this
two to three exposures per week minimum
of 20 to 30 minutes of sunlight exposure
onto as much of your body as you can
reasonably expose it to and when i say
reasonably i mean of course you have to
obey cultural constraints decency
constraints uh and
of course you have to also obey the fact
that sunlight can burn your skin
so many people are probably going to ask
what happens if you wear sunscreen
well in theory because sunscreen has uv
protection it would block some of these
effects i'm not suggesting that people
do away with sunscreen entirely i do
hope to do an episode all about
sunscreen in the future because
sunscreen is a bit of a controversial
topic skin cancers are a real thing and
many people are especially prone to skin
cancer so you need to take that
seriously some people are not very prone
to skin cancers and can tolerate much
more sun exposure
you're probably familiar with the simple
fact that if you've gone outside on the
beach with friends some people get
burned very easily others don't so you
really should prioritize the health and
the avoidance of sunburn on your skin
however
these data and other data point to the
fact that we should all probably be
striving to get more sunlight exposure
onto our skin during the winter months
and still getting sunlight exposure onto
our skin in the summer months provided
we can do that without damaging our skin
another set of very impressive effects
of uvv light whether or not it comes
from sunlight or from an artificial
source
is the effect of uvb light on our
tolerance for pain it turns out that our
tolerance for pain varies across the
year
and that our pain tolerance is increased
in
longer day conditions and as we saw with
the effects of uvb on hormones and
mating
again this is occurring via
uvb exposure to the skin and uvb
exposure to the eyes i want to just
describe two studies that really capture
the essence of these results
i'm going to discuss these in kind of a
top contour fashion i won't go into it
as quite as much depth as i did the last
study but i will provide links to these
studies as well
the first study is entitled skin
exposure to ultraviolet b
rapidly activate systemic neuroendocrine
and immunosuppressive responses and you
might hear that and think oh
immunosuppressive that's bad but
basically what they observed is that
even one exposure to uvb light changed
the output of particular hormones and
neurochemicals in the body such as
corticotropin hormone and beta
endorphins which are these endogenous
opioids we've all heard of the opioid
crisis which is people getting addicted
to opioids that they are taking in drug
form
pharmaceuticals but
here i'm referring to endorphins that
our body naturally manufactures and
releases in order to counter pain and
act as a somewhat of a psychological
soother also
because of course physical pain and
emotional pain are intimately linked in
the brain and body what they found was
that exposure to uvb light
increased the release of these beta
endorphins
it caused essentially the release of an
endogenous painkiller now a second study
that came out very recently
just this last week in fact published in
the journal neuron cell press journal
excellent journal
is entitled a visual circuit related to
the periaqueductal gray area for the
antinocioceptive effects of bright light
treatment i'll translate a little bit of
that for you
the periaqueductal gray is a region of
the midbrain that
contains a lot of neurons that can
release endogenous opioids things like
beta and kefilin things like encephalin
things like mu opioid these are all
names of chemicals that your body can
manufacture that act as endogenous
painkillers and increase your tolerance
for pain they actually make you feel
less pain overall by shutting down some
of the neurons that perceive pain or by
reducing their activity not to a
dangerous level right they're not going
to block the pain response so that you
burn yourself unnecessarily or harm
yourself unnecessarily but they act as a
bit of a painkiller from the inside
if you heard the word antinociceptive
nociception is
basically the perception or the way in
which neurons respond to painful stimuli
so you can think of nociceptive events
in your nervous system as painful events
and there i'm using a broad brush i
realize that the experts in pain will
say oh it's not a really a pain circuit
et cetera et cetera but
for sake of today's discussion it's fair
to say that necesseption is the
perception of pain so if this title is a
visual circuit related to the
periaqueductal gray which is this area
that releases these endogenous opioids
for the antinocioceptive the anti-pain
effects of bright light treatment
the key finding of this study is that it
is light
landing on the eyes and
captured by the specific cells i was
talking about earlier those
intrinsically photosensitive melanops
and ganglion cells is the long name for
them but these particular neurons in
your eye and in my eye
incidentally that communicate with
particular brain areas
these brain areas have names if you want
to know them for you aficionados or for
you ultra curious folks they have names
like the ventral lateral geniculate
nucleus and the intrageniculate leaflet
the names don't matter the point is that
light landing on the eyes
is captured by these melanopsin cells
they absorb that light translate that
light into electrical signals that are
handed off to areas of the brain such as
the ventral geniculate
and then the ventral geniculate
communicates with this periaqueductal
gray area to evoke the release of these
endogenous opioids that soothe you and
lead to less perception of pain
this is a really important study because
it's long been known that in longer days
or in bright light environments we
tolerate emotional and physical pain
better
previous studies had shown that it is
light landing on our skin
that mediates that effect but only in
part it couldn't explain the entire
effect this very recent study indicates
that it's also light arriving at the
eyes and in this case again uvb light
ultraviolet blue light of the sword that
comes from sunlight
that is triggering these anti-pain or
pain relieving pathways so once again we
have two parallel pathways this is a
theme you're going to hear over and over
and over again not just in this episode
but in all episodes of the huberman lab
podcast because this is the way that
your brain and body are built nature
rarely relies on one mechanism in order
to create an important phenomenon and
pain relief is an important phenomenon
so we now have at least two examples of
the potent effects of uvb light exposure
to the skin and to the eyes one
involving
activation of testosterone and estrogen
pathways as it relates to mating and
another that relates to
reducing the total amount of pain that
we experience in response to any painful
stimuli so for those of you that are
thinking tools and protocols if you're
somebody who's experiencing chronic pain
provided you can do it safely try to get
some uvb exposure ideally from sunlight
i think the 20 to 30 minute protocol two
or three times per week is an excellent
one it seems like a fairly low dose of
uvb light exposure it's hard to imagine
getting much damage to the skin of
course if you have very sensitive skin
or if you live in an area of the world
that is very very bright and has intense
sunlight
particular times of year you'll want to
be cautious heed the warnings and
considerations about sunscreen that i
talked about earlier or about wearing a
hat but
the point is very clear most of us
should be getting more uvb exposure from
sunlight
i can already hear the screams within
the comments or the rather the questions
within the comments saying well what if
i live in a part of the world where i
don't get much uvb exposure and i want
to emphasize something that i've also
emphasized in the many discussions on
this podcast related to sleep and
circadian rhythms and alertness which is
even on a cloud covered day you are
going to get far more light energy
photons
through cloud cover
then you are going to get from an indoor
light source an artificial light source
i can't emphasize this enough
if you look outside in the morning and
you see some sunlight
if you see some sunlight throughout the
day you would do yourself a great favor
to try and chase some of that sunlight
and get into that sunlight to expose
your eyes and your skin to that sunlight
as much as you safely can and when i say
as much as you safely can
never ever look at any light artificial
sunlight or otherwise that's so bright
that it's painful to look at it's fine
to get that light arriving on your eyes
indirectly it's fine to wear eyeglasses
or contact lenses in fact if you think
about the biology of the eye and the way
that those lenses work it will just
serve to focus
that light on to the very cells that you
want those light beams to be delivered
to whereas sunglasses that are highly
reflective or trying to get your
sunlight exposure through a windshield
of a car or through a window simply
won't work
i'm sorry to tell you but most windows
are designed to filter out the uvb light
and if you're somebody who's really keen
on blue blockers and you're wearing your
blue blockers all day
well don't wear them outside and in fact
you're probably doing yourself a
disservice by wearing them in the
morning and in the daytime there
certainly is a place for blue blockers
in the evening and night time if you're
having issues with falling and staying
asleep but if you think about it blue
blockers what they're really doing is
blocking those short wavelength uvb
wavelengths of light that you so
desperately need to arrive at your
retina and of course also onto your skin
in order to get these powerful
biological effects on hormones and on
pain
reduction and in terms of skin exposure
these data also might make you think a
little bit about whether or not you
should wear short sleeves or long
sleeves whether or not you want to wear
shorts or a skirt or pants it's all
going to depend on the context of your
life and the social and other variables
that are important of course i don't
know each and every one of your
circumstances so i can't tell you to do
x or y or z uh nor would i but you might
take into consideration that it is the
total amount of skin exposure that is
going to allow you to capture more or
fewer photons depending on
for instance if you're completely
cloaked in clothing and you're just you
know exposed in the hands
neck and face such as i am now or
whether or not you're outside in shorts
and a t-shirt you're going to get very
very different patterns of biological
signaling activation in those two
circumstances many of you i'm guessing
are wondering whether or not you should
seek out uvb exposure throughout the
entire year or only in the summer months
and that's sort of going to depend on
whether or not you experience
depression
in the winter months so-called seasonal
affective disorder
some people have mild some people have
severe forms of seasonal affective
disorder some people love the fall and
winter and the shorter days they love
bundling up they love the leaves they
love the snow they love the cold and
they don't experience those
psychological lows so it varies
tremendously and there are genetic
differences and uh
birthplace origin differences that
relate to all this but really it has to
be considered on a case-by-case basis
i personally believe and this was
reinforced by
the director of the
chronobiology unit at the national
institutes of mental health sarah hattar
that we would all do well to get more
uvb exposure from sunlight throughout
the entire year provided we aren't
burning our skin or damaging our eyes in
some way
in addition to that during the winter
months if you do experience some
drop in energy or
increase in depression or psychological
lows
it can be very beneficial to access a
sad lamp
or if you don't want to buy a sad lamp
because oftentimes they can be very
expensive you might do well to simply
get a led lighting panel i've described
one before and i want to emphasize that
i have no
affiliation whatsoever to these
commercial sources but i've described
one before and i'll describe it again
and we can provide a link to a couple
examples of these in the show note in
the show note captions excuse me
this is a
930-1000 lux lux
light source that's designed for drawing
it's literally a drawing box it's a thin
panel it's about the size of a laptop
very inexpensive compared to the typical
sad lamp i actually have one that i
position on my desk all day long i also
happen to have skylights above my desk
i'm fairly sensitive to the effects of
light so in longer days i feel much
better than i do in shorter days i've
never suffered from full-blown seasonal
affective disorder but i keep that
light source on throughout the day
throughout the year but i also make it a
point to get outside and get sunlight
early in the morning and several times
throughout the day and if it's
particularly overcast outside
or there just doesn't seem to be a lot
of sunlight coming through those clouds
i will try to look at that light source
a little bit more each day in order to
trigger these mechanisms
now some people may desire to get uvb
exposure to their skin and they want to
do that through sources other than
sunlight and there it's a little bit
more complicated there are of course
canning salons which basically are beds
of uvb light that's really all they are
i've never been to one i know people do
frequent them in certain parts of the
world
there of course people are covering
their eyes they are only getting uvb
exposure to their skin typically because
the uvb exposure or intensities rather
tends to be very very high and so you
can actually damage your eyes if you're
looking at a very very bright artificial
uvb source up close so you really have
to explore these options for yourself
sunlight of course being the original
and
still the best way to get uvb exposure
so without knowing your particular
circumstances finances genetics or place
of origin
etc i can't know whether or not you need
to use artificial sources you're going
to have to gauge that meanwhile getting
outside
looking at and getting some exposure
of uvb onto your skin is going to be
beneficial for the vast majority of
people out there
and in fact it's even going to be
beneficial for people that are
blind people that are blind provided
they still have eyes often maintain
these melanopsin cells
so even if you're low vision or no
vision getting uvb exposure to your eyes
can be very beneficial for sake of mood
hormone pathways pain reduction and so
forth
a cautionary note
people who have retinitis pigmentosa
macular degeneration or glaucoma as well
as people who are especially prone to
skin cancers should definitely consult
with your ophthalmologists and
dermatologists before you start
increasing the total amount of uvb
exposure that you're getting from any
source sunlight or otherwise there are
additional very interesting and powerful
effects of uvb
light in particular on immune function
all the organs of our body are inside
our skin and so information about
external conditions meaning the
environment that we're in need to be
communicated to the various organs of
our body
some of them have more direct access to
what's going on outside so for instance
the
cells in your brain that reside right
over the roof of your mouth your
hypothalamus that control hormone output
and then control the
biological functions that we call
circadian functions the ones that change
every 24 hours
well those are just one or two
connections meaning synapses away from
those cells in your eye that perceive
you be uvb light excuse me
other organs of your body such as your
spleen which is involved in the creation
of molecules and cells that combat
infection
well those are a long ways away from
those cells in your eye and in fact
they're a long ways away from your skin
there are beautiful studies showing that
if we get more uvb exposure from
sunlight or from appropriate artificial
sources
that
spleen and immune function are enhanced
and
there's a very logical well-established
circuit as to how that happens
your brain actually connects to your
spleen
now it's not the case that you can
simply think okay spleen turn on release
killer cells go out and combat infection
however
uvb light arriving on the eyes is known
to trigger activation of the neurons
within the so-called sympathetic nervous
system these neurons are part of the
larger thing that we call the autonomic
nervous system meaning it's below or not
accessible by conscious control it's the
thing that controls your heartbeat
controls your breathing and that also
activates or flips on the switch of your
immune system
when we get a lot of uvb light in our
eyes or i should say sufficient uvb
light in our eyes
a particular channel a particular set of
connections within the sympathetic
nervous system is activated and our
spleen deploys immune cells and
molecules that scavenge for and combat
infection so if you've noticed that you
get fewer colds and flus and other forms
of illness in the summer months
part of that could be because
of the increase in temperature in your
environment because typically longer
days are associated with more warmth in
your environment as opposed to winter
days which are short when it tends to be
colder out
well
that's true but it's also the case the
people around you have fewer colds and
flus and that you will get infected with
fewer colds and flus and other
infections
because
if those infections whether or not
they're bacterial or viral arrive in
your body right if you inhale them or
they get into your mouth or on your skin
your spleen meets those infections with
a greater output in other words the
soldiers of your immune system the
chemicals and cell types of your immune
system
that combat infection are in a
more ready deployed stance if you will
if you want to know more about the
immune system and immune function i did
an entire episode about the immune
system and the brain in a you can find
that at hubermanlab.com we talk about
cytokines we talk about killer cells b
cells t cells et cetera a lot of detail
there
so we often think about the summer
months and the spring months as fewer
infections floating around but in fact
there aren't fewer infections floating
around we are simply better at combating
those infections and therefore there's
less
infection floating around so we are
still confronted with a lot of
infections we're just able to combat
them better
what does this mean in terms of a tool
what it means is that during the winter
months we should be especially conscious
of accessing uvb light to enhance our
spleen function
to make sure that our sympathetic
nervous system is activated to a
sufficient level to keep our immune
system deploying all those killer t
cells and b cells and cytokines so that
when we encounter the infections as we
inevitably will right we're constantly
being bombarded with potential
infections that we can combat those
infections well and as just a brief
aside but i should mention a brief aside
that's related to tens of thousands of
quality studies
it is well known that wound healing is
faster when we are getting sufficient
uvb exposure
typically that's associated with the
longer days of spring and summer
it is known that
turnover of hair cells the very cells
that give rise to hair cells are called
stem cells they live in little so-called
niches in our skin with these hair stem
cells and your hair grows faster in
longer days that too is triggered by uvb
exposure not just to the skin but to the
eyes
that's right there was a study published
in the proceedings of the national
academy of sciences
a couple of years ago that showed that
the exposure of those melanops and
ganglion cells in your eyes is
absolutely critical for triggering the
turnover of stem cells in both the skin
and hair and also it turns out in nails
so if you've noticed that your skin your
hair and your nails look better and turn
over more meaning grow faster in
longer days that is not a coincidence
that is not just your perception in fact
hair grows more skin turns over more
meaning it's going to look more youthful
you're going to essentially remove
older skin cells and replace them with
new cells and all the renewing cells and
tissues of our body are going to
proliferate are going to recreate
themselves more when we're getting
sufficient uvb light to our eyes and
also to our skin and so while some of
you may think of
light therapies such as red light
therapies or uvb therapies as kind of
new new-agey or just bio-hacking again a
phrase i don't particularly like this
notion of biohacking because it implies
using one thing for a purpose that it
was never intended to have
well
it turns out that uvb exposure and red
light as we'll soon see is a very potent
form of increasing things like wound
healing and skin health for very logical
mechanistically backed
reasons
so
while i can't account for everything
that's being promoted out there in terms
of this light source will help your skin
look more youthful or will help
heal your scars
the mechanistic basis for light having
those effects makes total sense
but what you should consider however is
that if the particular light therapy
that you're considering involves very
local application rather than
illuminating broad swaths of skin
and if it has no involvement with the
eyes meaning there's no
delivery of uvb or red light or the
other light therapy to the eyes
it's probably not going to be as potent
a treatment as would a more systemic
activation of larger areas of skin and
the eyes now again a cautionary note i
don't want people taking technologies
that were designed for local application
and beaming those into the eyes that
could be very very bad and damaging to
your retinal and other tissues
certainly when you taking
bright light of very high intensity of
any kind and getting cavalier about that
typically the local
illumination of say a wound or a
particular patch of acne or some other
form of skin treatment involves very
high intensity light and if the
intensity is too high you can actually
damage that skin and so as we'll talk
about in a few moments most of those
therapies for modifying skin involve
actually burning off a small very thin
layer at the top of the epidermis in
efforts to trigger the renewal or the
activation of stem cells that will
replenish that with new cells
so
there's a fine line to be had between
light therapies that are very localized
and intense which are designed to damage
skin and cause reactivation
of
new stem cells whether or not it's hair
cells or skin cells etc versus systemic
activation across broad swaths of skin
in the eyes you really have to consider
this on a case-by-case basis but at
least for now just consider that
increases in hormones reduction in pain
by way of increases in and keflan and
other endogenous opioids
improving immune status by activating
the spleen and so on and so on
really are all the downstream
consequence of illuminating large swaths
of skin and making sure that those
neurons and within the eye get their
adequate uvb exposure or other light
wavelength exposure not simply beaming a
particular wavelength of light at a
particular location on the body and
hoping that that particular illumination
at a particular location on the body is
going to somehow change the biology at
that location our biologies just really
doesn't work that way it's possible but
in general systemic effects through
broad scale illumination and
illumination to the eye combined with
local treatments are very likely to be
the ones that have the most success now
i'd like to shift our attention to the
effects of light on mood more
specifically we talked about this in
terms of seasonal affective disorder but
many of us don't suffer from seasonal
affective disorder so i'd like to drill
a little deeper into how light impacts
mood
and
here i want to again paraphrase the
statements of
dr samuel hatar
at the national institutes of mental
health i should mention the director of
the chronobiology unit at the national
institutes of mental health and
perhaps one of the top
one to two to three world experts in how
light can impact mood appetite circadian
rhythms and so forth
sammer stated on the podcast and he said
in various other
venues as well that getting as much uvb
light in our eyes and on our skin in the
early day and throughout the day as is
safely possible is going to be
beneficial for mood
there's also another time of day or
rather i should say a time of night in
which uvb can be leveraged in order to
improve mood
but it's actually the inverse of
everything we've been talking about up
until now
we have a particular neural circuit that
originates with those melanopsin cells
in our eye
that bypass all the areas of the brain
associated with circadian clocks so
everything related to sleep and
wakefulness that's specifically
dedicated to the pathways involving the
release of molecules like dopamine the
neuromodulator that's associated with
motivation with
feeling good with feeling like there's
possibility in the world and so on and
so forth and other molecules as well
including serotonin and some of those
endogenous opioids that we talked about
before
that particular pathway involves a brain
structure called the perihebenular
nucleus the perihebenular nucleus gets
input from the cells in the eye that
respond to uvb light and frankly to
bright light of other wavelengths as
well because as you recall if a light is
bright enough even if it's not uv or
blue light it can activate those cells
in the eye those cells in the eye
communicate to the perihelion nucleus
and as it turns out if this pathway is
activated at the wrong time of each
24-hour cycle
mood
gets worse dopamine output gets worse
molecules that are there specifically to
make us feel good actually are reduced
in their output
so while uvb exposure in the morning and
throughout the day
is going to be very important for
elevating and maintaining elevated mood
avoiding uvb light
at night is actually a way in which we
can
prevent activation of this
eye to perihelia pathway that can
actually turn on depression to be very
direct and succinct about this
avoid exposure to uvb light from
artificial sources
between the hours of 10 pm and 4 a.m and
if you're somebody who suffers from low
mood
and overall has a kind of mild
depression or even severe depression of
course please see a psychiatrist see a
trained psychologist get that treated
but
you would do especially well to avoid
uvb exposure from artificial sources not
just from 10 pm to 4am but really be
careful about getting too much exposure
to uvb even in the late evening so 8 pm
perhaps to 4 am
i can't emphasize this enough
that if you view uvb light you activate
those neurons in your eye very potently
and if those cells communicate to the
perihelvenular nucleus which they do you
will truncate or reduce the amount of
dopamine that you release
so
if you want to keep your mood elevated
get a lot of light uvb light throughout
the day
and at night really be cautious about
getting uvb exposure from artificial
sources now let's say you're somebody
who has no issues with mood you're just
the happiest person all year long or
maybe you just have subtle
variations in your mood you feel great
about that
turns out that you still want to be very
careful about light exposure between the
hours of 10 pm or so and 4 am in fact
even during sleep there's a recent study
that just came out in the proceedings of
the national academy of sciences
and it's entitled light exposure during
sleep impairs cardiometabolic function
this is a very interesting study where
they took human subjects young adults
and having them sleep in rooms that had
different lighting conditions either dim
light or
slightly bright light now many people
can't fall asleep in brightly lit rooms
so they acknowledge this these were not
very brightly lit rooms these were rooms
that had just a little bit of overhead
room lighting a hundred lux which is not
very bright at all or they had them
sleep in a room that had very dim light
which is less than three lux if you want
to get a sense of how bright three lux
is versus a hundred lux i would
encourage you to download the free app
light meter i have no relationship to
the app it's a pretty cool app however
i've used it for a long time where you
can basically point your phone
at a particular light source sun or
otherwise and you just press the button
it'll give you an approximate readout of
lux which is the light intensity that
the phone happens to be staring out at
at that location it's not
exact but it's a pretty good back of the
envelope measure of light intensity so
these subjects were either sleeping in a
very dim room three lux is very very dim
or a
somewhat dim room 100 lux
in this study they measured things like
melatonin levels they looked at heart
rate they looked at measures of
insulin
and glucose management now in
previous episodes i've talked about how
glucose blood sugar is regulated by
insulin because you don't want your
glucose levels to be too high
hyperglycemia or too low hypoglycemia
and the hormone insulin is involved in
sequestering and shuttling glucose in
the bloodstream basically how well you
manage glucose in the bloodstream can be
indirectly measured by your insulin
levels and it's well known that sleep
deprivation
can disrupt glucose
regulation by
insulin
however in this study subjects were
sleeping the whole night through it just
so happens that some of the subjects
were sleeping in this very dimly lit
room three locks and other subjects were
sleeping in a
somewhat dimly lit room 100 lux
what's incredible about this study is
that both rooms were sufficiently dim
that melatonin levels were not altered
in either case this is really key it's
not as if one group experienced a lot of
bright light through their eyelids and
others did not melatonin levels were not
disrupted and given how potently light
can inhibit melatonin this speaks to the
fact that this very dim condition of 3
lux and the somewhat dim condition of
100 lux was not actually perceived by
the subjects
nor was it disrupting these hormone
pathways they also looked at glucose
responses they had people essentially
take a fasting glucose test in different
conditions i won't go into all the
details but here's what they found in
healthy adults even just one night of
sleeping in a moderately
lit environment this hundred lux
environment
caused changes increases in nighttime
heart rate which means that the
sympathetic nervous system was overly
active as compared to people that slept
in a completely dark or in a very very
dimly lit room decreases in heart rate
variability and here i should point out
that heart rate variability or hrv is a
good thing we want heart rate
variability so they saw increases in
heart rate decreases in heart rate
variability and increases in next
morning insulin resistance
which is an indication that glucose
management is suffering
so
this is powerful the results of this
study essentially indicate that even
just one night of sleeping the whole
night through in a dimly lit environment
is disrupting the way that our autonomic
nervous system is functioning
altering so-called autonomic tone making
us less relaxed is probably the best way
to describe it
even though we are asleep disrupting the
way that our
cardiometabolic function operates such
that we have lower heart rate
variability and
increased insulin resistance
this is not a good thing for any of us
to experience so while we've mainly been
talking about the positive effects of
uvb light and other forms of light
now we have two examples one from the
work of hatar and kali showing that uvb
exposure
via the perihebenula can diminish the
output of dopamine and other molecules
that make us feel good if that uvb
exposure is in the middle of the night
or late evening
and now we have yet another study
performed in this case in humans
indicating that even if we fall asleep
and sleep the whole night through if the
room that we're sleeping in has too many
lux too much light energy that light
energy is no doubt going through the
eyelids which it can
activating the particular cells in the
eye that trigger
an increase in sympathetic nervous
system activation and disrupting our
metabolism and this study rests on a
number of other recent studies published
in cell which is a superb journal and
other journals showing that during the
course of a healthy deep night sleep
our body actually transitions through
various forms of metabolic function we
actually experience
ketosis-like states we experience
gluconeogenesis we experience different
forms of metabolism associated with
different stages of sleep not something
that we're going into in depth in this
podcast we will in a future podcast
what this study shows is that
light exposure even in sleep is
disrupting our autonomic in this case
the sympathetic arm of the autonomic
nervous system in ways that are
disrupting metabolism probably in sleep
but certainly outside of sleep so we
wake up and have our first meal of the
day or even if you're intermittent
fasting you eat that first meal of the
day if your sleep is taking place in an
environment that's overly illuminated
well that's disrupting your cardiac
function and your metabolism i've been
talking a lot about uvb light which is
short wavelength light so uv light blue
light maybe even some blue green light
that's going to be short wavelength
light now i'd like to shift our
attention to the other end of the
spectrum meaning the light spectrum to
talk about red light and infrared light
which is long wavelength light many
so-called low-level light therapies
the acronym is lllt low-level light
therapies involve the use of red light
and infrared light
sometimes low-level light therapies
involve the use of uvb but more often
than not these days when we hear lllt
low-level light therapy it's referring
to red light and near-infrared light
therapies
low-level light therapies have been
shown to be effective for a huge number
of biological phenomenon and medical
treatments
i can't summarize all of those now it
would take me many many hours to be an
effective episode for curing insomnia
but it wouldn't inform you properly
about the use of light for your health
rather i'd like to just emphasize some
of the top contour of those studies and
point out that for instance
low-level light therapy with infrared
light has been shown to be effective for
the treatment of acne and other sorts of
skin lesions there's been some really
nice studies actually
where they use subjects as their own
internal control so people believe it or
not agreed to have half of their face
illuminated with red light or
near-infrared light and the other half
of their face serve as a control and to
do that for several weeks at a time and
you can see pretty impressive reductions
in skin lesions
reductions in scars from acne and
reduction in acne lesions themselves
meaning the accumulation of new acne
cysts with low level light therapy using
red light and infrared light
sometimes however
there is a resistance of that acne to
the low-level light therapy such that
people will get an initial improvement
and then it will go away despite
continuing the treatment so you're
probably asking or at least you should
be asking how is it that shining red
light on our skin can impact things like
acne and wound healing etc
well to understand that we have to think
back to the beginning of the episode
where i described how long wavelength
light such as red light and
near-infrared light which is even longer
than red light can pass through
certain surfaces including our skin so
our skin has an epidermis which is on
the outside and the dermis which is in
the deeper layers
red light and infrared light can pass
down into the deeper layers of our skin
where it can change the metabolic
function of particular cells so let's
just take acne as an example
within the dermis the deep layers of our
skin we have what are called sebaceous
glands that actually make the oil
that is present in our skin those
sebaceous glands are often nearby hair
follicles so if you've ever had an
infected hair follicle
that's not a coincidence that hair
follicles tend to get infected part of
it is because there's actually a portal
down and around the hair follicle but
the sebaceous gland is where the oil is
created that is going to give rise to
for instance acne lesions
also in the dermis and the deep layers
of the skin
are the melanocytes they're not just in
the epidermis they're also in the deeper
layers of the skin and
you have the stem cells that give rise
to
additional skin cells if the top layers
of the epidermis are damaged those stem
cells can become activated and
you also have the stem cells that give
rise to hair follicles so by shining red
light
or near infrared light on a localized
patch of skin provided that red light is
not of such high intensity that it burns
the skin but is of sufficient intensity
that provides just a little bit of
damage to the upper layers of the skin
the epidermis
and that it triggers certain biological
pathways within the cells of the
sebaceous gland and the stem cells
within the hair cell niche and the stem
cells in skin what happens is the top
layers of the skin are basically burned
off by a very low level of burn
and or the cells in the deeper layer
start to churn out new cells which go
and rescue the lesion essentially
clear out the lesion and replace that
lesion with healthy skin cells
this does work in the context of wound
healing
getting scars to disappear it also works
to remove certain patches of
pigmentation there are sometimes cases
where people will get a red blotchiness
due to certain skin conditions or some
darker pigmentation that they want
remover that they need removed because
it's a potential skin cancer threat
now how is red light actually doing it
within the cells of the sebaceous gland
the stem cells etc well long wavelength
light can actually get deep into the
skin i mentioned that before but can
also get into individual cells
and can access the so-called organelles
which i described at the beginning of
the episode in particular they can
access the mitochondria which are
responsible for producing atp now the
simple way to think about this for sake
of this discussion is that
as cells age and in particular in very
metabolically active cells
they accumulate what are called
roses reactive oxygen species and
as reactive oxygen species go up
atp energy production in those cells
tends to go down it's a general
statement but it's a general statement
that in most cases is true
there are some minor exceptions that
don't concern us that have to do with
cell types different than the ones that
i'm talking about now so the way to
think about this is that red light
passes into the deeper layers of the
skin activates mitochondria which
increases atp and directly or indirectly
reduces these reactive oxygen species
these reactive oxygen species are not
good we don't want them they cause
cellular damage cell or death
and for the most part just inhibit the
way that our cells work
so if you've heard of red light or
near-infrared light therapies
designed to heal skin or improve skin
quality or remove lesions or get rid of
scars or unwanted pigmentation
that is not
pseudoscience that is not
woo science that is grounded in the very
biology of how light interacts with
mitochondria and reactive oxygen species
some of you may also find it interesting
to note that some of the cream-based
treatments for acne for instance like
retinoic acid retin-a
is actually a derivative of vitamin a
and the pathway involving retinoic acid
and vitamin a believe it or not is very
similar to the natural biological
pathway by which photo pigments in the
eye convert light information into
biological changes within those cells so
the key point here is that light is
activating particular pathways in cells
that can either drive death of cells or
can make those cells essentially younger
by increasing atp by way of improving
mitochondrial function
and in recent years there have been some
just beautiful examples that exist not
only in the realm of skin biology but in
the realm of neurobiology
whereby red light and near-infrared
light can actually be used to enhance
the function of the cells that for
instance allow us to see better and
indeed cells that allow us to think
better so now i'd like to review those
data because not only are they
interesting in their own right
but they also point to some very
interesting and powerful application of
low-cost or zero-cost tools that we can
use to improve our vision if you are
somebody who's interested in the use of
red light or near-infrared light
so-called lllt low-level light therapies
for treatment of dermatologic issues so
anything related to skin i will include
a link to a excellent set of reviews the
first one is light emitting diodes and
dermatology a systematic review of
randomized controlled trials
that one includes review of a very large
number of studies came out just a few
years ago in 2018 and i think is very
clearly and cleanly laid out for anyone
to access you can see the degree of
effects of red light for instance on
treatment of acne or scarring etc and
i'll also provide a link to another
review which is low level light therapy
in skin stimulating healing and
restoring so for those of you that are
interested again in dermatologic issues
and the kind of
restoring youthfulness and the kind of
uh general themes of of anti-aging and
longevity and how red light therapies
can be used for that i would encourage
you to take a look at those reviews what
you're going to find is that rarely if
ever
is there a study looking at whole body
red light illumination for sake of
treating and improving skin
and i mentioned this because i get a lot
of questions about infrared sauna and
global illumination with red lights
we'll talk more about cases where global
illumination of your whole body or your
whole face with red lights might be
useful but in terms of infrared sauna
i've mentioned on this podcast before
and i will certainly go deeper on this
in an upcoming episode all about the use
of heat and temperature for augmenting
our biology but in general
infrared saunas don't get hot enough
temperature wise in order to trigger
some of the important effects on growth
hormone and heat shock proteins and some
of the other things that sauna has been
shown to be excellent for
that's a general statement i realize
there are some infrared saunas that do
get hot enough
there are very few data on the use of
whole body illumination with infrared
saunas they really point to any specific
mechanistically supported effects almost
all the positive effects that you're
going to see of red light and low-level
light therapies
certainly the ones discussed in the
reviews that i just mentioned are going
to be the consequence of very directed
illumination of particular patches of
skin that are seeking repair that people
are seeking the repair of so again i
don't want to disparage
infrared saunas but in general they
don't get hot enough to trigger most of
the positive effects that sauna have
been demonstrated to have and
it's unclear at all as to whether or not
they can enhance skin quality
youthfulness restore
you know
top layers of skin that are damaged
repair acne etc so more on heat saunas
and infrared saunas in their comparison
in an upcoming episode so let's talk
about a clear set of examples where
red light and near-infrared light have
been shown to have positive effects on
our health and these are the data that i
refer to at the beginning of the episode
from dr glenn jeffrey at university
college london who
again
is a long-standing member of the
neuroscience community working on visual
neuroscience and who over the last
decade or so has really emphasized the
exploration of red light and
near-infrared light for restoration of
neuronal function as we age this is
absolutely critical we know that we
don't accumulate many
new brain cells as we get older and in
some areas of our nervous system such as
our neural retina which is the part of
our eye that's responsible for
translating light information to
electrical signals so that we can see we
don't get any new cells after the time
in which we are born so the ability to
keep our neurons healthy is extremely
important for our visual system
extremely important for our hippocampus
an area of the brain involved in memory
and
i should just mention that even if
people don't get alzheimer's there's
always going to be some degree of
age-related dementia
sadly nobody is as cognitively sharp
in the years before they die as they are
20 years before that it's just never the
case we're all getting worse at thinking
feeling perceiving etc the question is
how quickly we are getting worse so any
mechanism by which we can preserve or
reverse neuronal function turns out to
be immensely beneficial
the jeffrey lab has published two
studies in recent years on humans that
looked directly
no pun intended at how red light and
near-infrared light can improve visual
function
i'm going to describe the parameters of
those studies and then i'm going to
describe what they found exactly
the mechanistic
motivation for these studies again
traces back to this effect of light on
mitochondria
so to go a little bit deeper into that
mechanism just briefly
so that you can frame any potential
protocol that you would develop
when light arrives on
cells
including neurons that light can
penetrate into the cells if it's of the
appropriate wavelength red light can do
that it can get into cells it can access
the mitochondria it can increase atp
in general anytime atp is doing its
thing to increase energy in cells
it's involving this
thing called cytochrome c which is an
oxidase anytime you hear ace ase in
biology it's going to be an enzyme it's
involved in some process of degrading a
molecule and creating another molecule
typically so atp and cytochrome c
is going to give you atp now that's a
great thing
but it creates a byproduct it breaks
things down such that you get these
roses these reactive oxygen species and
those reactive oxygen species for those
of you that want to know are involved in
things like redox signaling and
reactive oxygen species actually change
which genes are made in a cell so the
goal of any treatment to keep neurons or
other cells youthful and functioning
well and
to prevent or reverse aging is going to
be to increase atp and to reduce
reactive oxygen species and in doing so
to disrupt some of the normal pathways
associated with aging
the jeffrey lab approached these studies
with that understanding of how
mitochondria and reactive oxygen species
in atp work
and what they did was exquisitely simple
to the point of being elegant and what
they found was really really exciting
what they did
is they had people
subjects that were either younger so in
their 20s or 40 years old or older
view red light of about 670 nanometers
670 nanometers would appear red to you
and me they had they had them do that
excuse me at a distance that was safe
for their eyes so at about a foot away
now
a foot away from a very intense red
light could actually be damaging to the
eyes so they had them do this about a
foot away from a red light that was of
low enough intensity that did not damage
the eyes and they had them do that
anywhere from two to three minutes per
day
and in one study they had them do that
for a long period of time of about 12
weeks and in the other study they had
them do that just for a couple of weeks
what's remarkable is that when you
collapse the results across these two
studies what they found is that when
looking at these subjects ranging from
28 years old to about 72 years old
the major findings were that in
individuals 40 years
old or older so in the 40 to 72
year old bracket but not in the subjects
younger than 40 years old they saw an
improvement in visual function
that improvement in visual function was
an improvement in visual acuity meaning
the ability to resolve fine detail and
using a particular measure of visual
function
which is called the triton
exam
t-r-i-t-a-n triton exam which
specifically addresses the function of
the so-called short wavelength cones the
ones that respond to green and blue
light they saw a 22 improvement in
visual acuity which
in the landscape of visual testing is an
extremely exciting result okay so i
think in most studies of improvements of
vision you'd be very excited to see an
improvement of 5 or 10
so a 22 improvement in visual acuity
even though it's in this very specific
form of visual testing this triton exam
or this triton score
well that turns out to be very
significant and translates to the real
world in an important way
in particular
as we age we tend to lose certain
neurons within our retina but we don't
tend to lose cones
we tend to lose rods we tend to lose
other cells within the retina including
the cells that connect the eye to the
brain the so-called ganglion cells cones
for whatever reason are pretty resilient
to age-related loss however
because rods and cones both
are not just among the most
metabolically active cells in your
entire body but the most metabolically
active cells in your entire body that's
right your rods and cones are the cells
that demand and that use the most energy
of all the cells in your body
not your skin cells not your spleen
cells not your stomach cells even if you
talk a lot not the cells that are
responsible for moving your mouth it is
the rods and cones of your neural retina
that are responsible for using the most
amount of atp and energy in your entire
body
and because of that those cells tend to
accumulate a lot of reactive oxygen
species as we age
red light of the sort used in these
studies was able to reduce the amount of
reactive oxygen species in the rods and
cones and to rescue the function of this
particular cone type the short
wavelength and medium wavelength cones
which if you think about the study is a
little bit surprising because it was red
light and near infrared light not short
wavelength light that was used in order
to create this improvement in cellular
function
but if you step back a little bit
further it makes perfect sense because
there's nothing specific about the red
light in the sense that it's not that it
gets delivered only to red cones that
red light and near-infrared light is
being absorbed by all the photoreceptors
within the eye the rods and the blue
cones and the green cones and the red
cones it's just that the red cones
absorb that light best
so
the important takeaway here is that
viewing red light and your infrared
light at a distance at which it is safe
for just a couple of minutes each day
allowed a reversal of the aging process
of these neurons which
some people have heard me say before and
i'll just say it again
the retina including your photoreceptors
are not just connected to your brain
they're not just near your brain they
are actual central nervous system tissue
they are the only two pieces of your
brain many are neural retinas are the
only two pieces of your brain that
reside outside your skull or at least
outside the cranial vault so here we're
seeing a reversal
of the aging process in neurons by
shining red light on those neurons now
of course the
jeffrey lab is primarily interested in
vision and humans are most dependent on
vision as a sense to navigate the world
and survive so this is really wonderful
here we're looking at a therapy that can
reverse age-related vision loss
at least in some individuals
but as you can imagine the study was
also done on these cells because they
reside outside the skull and you can
shine light directly on them right i'm
sure that there are many people out
there who are interested in how they can
improve the function say of the neurons
in their brain responsible for memory
and in a few minutes i'll describe the
non-invasive
applications of light to try and restore
the function of those cells as well
so a little bit more about the studies
from the jeffree lab
one of the things that they observed was
a reduction in so-called drusen
d-r-u-s-e-n druzen are little
fatty deposits little cholesterol
deposits that accumulate in the eye as
we age
we've all heard about cholesterol within
our veins and arteries and how that can
clog our veins and arteries
and how
of course clogging of veins and arteries
is not a good thing well our neural
retina being so metabolically active
requires a lot of blood flow it's
heavily vascularized and
drusen are a special form of cholesterol
that accumulate in the eye
as it turns out these red light and
near-infrared light therapies explored
by the jeffrey lab were able to actually
reduce or reverse some of the
accumulation of druzen and so in
addition to reducing reactive oxygen
species
the idea in mind now is that red light
may actually reduce cholesterol deposits
and reactive oxygen species in order to
improve neuronal function
so what should you and i do with these
results or should we do anything with
these results well first of all i want
to emphasize that even though these
studies are very exciting
they are fairly recent and so more data
as always are needed
there's some additional features of
these studies that i think are also
important to consider first of all
the exposure to red light
needed to happen early in the day at
least within the first three hours of
waking
how would one do that well nowadays
there are a number of different red
light panels
and different red light sources that
certainly fall within the range of red
light and near infrared light that one
could use
i don't have any affiliation to any
companies or products that
promote or make those red light
therapies
i do own a red light panel so i confess
i have started using this protocol i am
older than 40 years old i also have been
experimenting with these red light
panels as a way of addressing other
changes in biological tissues
for which i'm doing blood work etc and
i'm going to talk about that in a future
episode but that of course is what i
call anik data it only relates to my
experience so
today and certainly on all episodes of
the human lab podcast we emphasize
peer-reviewed studies almost exclusively
talking about anecdata only when
highlighting it as anecdata so if you're
somebody who wants to explore red light
therapy
here's what you need to do you need to
make sure that that red light source
whatever
source you happen to use whether or not
you purchase it or make one and in fact
these red light sources are very very
easy to make you could essentially take
a bright flashlight and cover it with a
film or a filter that would only allow
particular long wavelengths to pass
through this would be very easy to look
up online and figure out how to do this
you could probably do this for you know
just a few dollars or you could purchase
a red light unit if that was within your
budget and something that you're
interested in you want to make sure that
it's not so bright that you're damaging
your eye
a good rule of thumb is that something
isn't painful to look at and in fact i
should just emphasize that anytime you
look at any light source sunlight or
otherwise that's painful it makes you
want to squint or close your eyes that
means it's too bright to look at without
closing your eyes okay that's sort of a
duh but i would loathe to think that
anyone would harm themselves with bright
light in any way i don't just say that
to protect us i say that to protect you
of course because you are responsible
for your health and again retinal
neurons do not regenerate once they are
gone and dead they do not come back
there is no technology to replace them
at this current state in time so please
don't damage your retinas so is a red
light source safe to look at if it is
not painful to look at
chances are it is and yet i would still
encourage you to talk to your
optometrist or ophthalmologist
before getting into any extensive
protocols but if you are still
determined to pursue the sorts of
protocols that are in the jeffree
studies certainly we'll provide a link
to those studies again it involved
looking at these red light panels
blinking aloud
for
two minutes to three minutes
every morning
for a period of two weeks
or more
and
if you're older than 40 that could very
well have an effect if you're longer
younger than 40 excuse me that's
unlikely to have an effect at least that
was what was observed in these
particular studies the lights were not
flashing it was continuous illumination
again you're allowed to blink it does
not have to even be direct illumination
it can be somewhat indirect illumination
much as we described for the use of uvb
light before
the wavelength of light is important it
is red light and near-infrared light
that is going to be
effective in this scenario the authors
of this study emphasized that it was red
light of 670 nanometers
in wavelength and near infrared light of
790 nanometers in wavelength that were
effective and that those wavelengths
could be complementary
that's probably why or maybe it's just
coincidental but it's a fortunate
coincidence that a lot of the
commercially available red light panels
that you'll find out there combine both
red light and near infrared light
however i want to emphasize that most of
the panels that are commercially
available
are going to be too bright to safely
look at very close up and in fact that's
why most of those red light panels are
designed for illumination of the skin
and oftentimes arrive in their packaging
with eye protectors that are actually
designed to shield out all the red light
so take the potential dangers of
excessive illumination of the eyes with
any wavelength of light seriously but if
you're going to explore 670 and 790
nanometer light for sake of
enhancing
neuronal function
set it at a distance that's comfortable
to look at and that doesn't force you to
squint or doesn't make you feel
uncomfortable physically as if you need
to turn away
during the period of that two to three
minute illumination each day
in terms of turning away from light i'll
just briefly mention that that is not an
accident or a coincidence that you have
that response to very bright light there
is a so-called photic avoidance pathway
that involves cells within your retina
these ganglion cells that communicate
with
yet another brain station a certain area
of your thalamus that communicate to
areas of your brain that are associated
with pain so literally that can trigger
headache and that can trigger the squint
reflex
biology is just beautiful in this way
too much light is bad for us and that it
can damage our eyes and other aspects of
our body so if we look at a light that's
too bright
our eyes send a signal to the brain that
gives us a sort of a headache and a
desire to squint and turn away so that
can be a useful guide in terms of
gauging how bright a light should be or
at least how far away you should be from
a bright source in order to safely
engage with that light source so the
studies i just described once again
involve the use of red light early in
the day within three hours of waking and
are for the sake of improving neuronal
function red light has also been shown
to be beneficial
late in the day and even in the middle
of the night and when i say middle of
the night i'm referring to studies that
explore the use of red light for shift
workers i know that most people are not
working in the middle of the night at
least i hope they're not but some of you
may do that from time to time
all-nighters for studying i confess i
still pull all-nighters every once in a
while to prepare things like podcasts
and other deadlines
really try not to happens less and less
as i get older because i think i get
more disciplined and or less good at
pulling all-nighters but i realize that
many people are doing shift work or they
have to work certainly past 10 pm or
maybe they're taking care of young
children in the middle of the night and
they have to be up in that case red
light can actually be very beneficial
and nowadays there are a lot of sources
of red light available just as red light
bulbs you don't need a panel so what i'm
basically saying is that it can be
beneficial to use red lights at night
the study i'd like to emphasize in this
context is entitled red light a novel
non-pharmacological intervention to
promote alertness in shift workers so
beautiful study they explored the use of
different wavelengths of light so blue
light of 460 nanometers or red light or
dim white light
of different brightnesses etc and looked
at things like
melatonin how much does light of a given
color in intensity suppress melatonin
they looked at cortisol a stress hormone
they looked at wakefulness
how much or to what degree could a given
color of light increase wakefulness at
different hours of the day the takeaway
from this study is very clear if you
need to be awake late at night for sake
of shift work or studying or
taking care of children etc red light is
going to be your best choice
because
if the red light is sufficiently dim
it's not going to inhibit melatonin
production and it's not going to
increase cortisol at night cortisol
should be high early in the day or at
least should be elevated relative to
other times a day if you are healthy a
late-shifted increase in cortisol
however 9 pm cortisol 10 pm cortisol is
well known to be associated with
depression and other aspects of mental
health rash is a mental illness
so if you do need to be awake at night
or even all night red light is going to
be the preferred light source
and in terms of how bright to make it
well as dim as you can while still being
able to perform the activities that you
need to perform that's going to be your
best guide
i'll provide a link to this study as
well
again
it's a really important study because it
emphasized that there are forms of light
red light provided it's dim that can
allow you to stimulate the alertness
that light
landing on the eyes can provide
so it allows you to stay awake and to do
whatever work that you need to do
it does not seem to alter melatonin
production so that's good it does not
seem to alter levels or timing of
cortisol production so yet another case
where red light used correctly can be
beneficial up until now we've been
talking about the effects of shining
different wavelengths of light on the
skin
or on our eyes and the downstream health
consequences of
that illumination however one of the
most important goals of science and
medicine is to figure out how to change
the health of our brain and of course
our brain is contained within our skull
and therefore we can't just shine light
onto the outside of our head and expect
it to change the activity of neurons
deep within the brain unless those
neurons are linked up
with
our eyes or with our skin and as it
turns out even though there are a lot of
brain areas that are connected through
neural circuits and hormone circuits to
our eye and believe it or not also to
our skin
many brain areas are not
brain areas such as the hippocampus
which is involved in learning and memory
brain areas such as our neocortex
well some areas of our neocortex such as
our visual cortex are indirectly linked
to our eyes so if we shine light on our
eyes we can change the activity of
neurons in our neocortex
but there are other brain areas
that are not directly or even indirectly
connected to our visual system not
at least in any immediate way so that
raises the question of how do you change
the activity of neurons in the brain
well there's pharmacology you can take
pills you can inject drugs that will
change the pharmacology of neurons and
the way they operate in fire of course
antidepressants are one such instance
opioid drugs are another
there's a huge array of psychoactive
compounds meaning compounds that will
change the levels of chemicals in your
brain
some of those work many of them also
carry side effects
it's all rather indirect
meaning you have lots of different cells
in different areas of your brain that
utilize the same chemicals so a drug for
instance to increase serotonin for sake
of
improving depression will also often
have the effect of reducing certain
neurons output of serotonin in the
hippocampus and cause changes in
appetite or changes in libido and so on
and so forth
you could imagine using electrical
stimulation putting wires into the brain
and stimulating specific brain areas in
order to activate the neurons in those
brain areas and certainly that works and
has been done experimentally and is done
during neurosurgery exams etc but
involves removing a piece of skull
so that's not very practical
in principle
light would be a wonderful way to
modulate the activity of neurons deep
within the brain
but again the skull is in the way
recent studies however have figured out
ways that light can be delivered to the
eyes to change global patterns of firing
in the brain in ways that can be
beneficial to the brain
and the work that i'm referring to now
is mainly the work of leeway tsai at mit
massachusetts institute of technology
and her colleagues
and what they've discovered is that
there's a particular pattern of brain
activity called gamma activity
gamma activity is one so-called
wavelength of
electrical activity in the brain so not
wavelengths of light but wavelengths of
electrical activity in the brain that
can be restorative for certain aspects
of learning and memory and can actually
help create molecular changes in neurons
that lead to clearance of debris and
even reductions in age-related cognitive
decline
so
the way to think about brain waves and
brain oscillations is that neurons are
electrically active that involves
chemicals etc and they can be active in
very slow big wave forms so you can
think of
you know delta waves meaning so you can
imagine a wave of electrical activity
that comes along very infrequently so a
given neuron fires and then some period
of time later
fires and then some period of time even
later fires or you can imagine that that
same cell is very active fires fires
fires fires fires you can imagine if
it's firing very often it's going to be
short wavelength right
shorter gaps between firing or
if it's firing very seldom you're going
to
think about that as longer wavelength
firing turns out that gamma waves are
one pattern of firing that leads to
downstream
metabolic functions and biological
functions that end up clearing away
debris that's associated with aging in
cells
and
that also lead to molecular changes that
enhance the kind of youthfulness of
neurons so to speak
how do we induce gamma oscillations
within the brain well
what leeway tsai and colleagues have
beautifully shown
is that
by delivering certain patterns of light
flicker
so lights going on and off at a
particular frequency
the brain as a whole
starts to entrain meaning it matches to
those particular patterns of light
flicker even though many of the brain
areas that do this are not directly
within the visual system or visual
pathway
so the studies that i'm referred to are
several but the one that i'd like to
highlight is entitled gamma entrainment
binds higher order brain regions and
offers neuro protection
what they essentially did
was to expose subjects to
40 hertz which is a particular frequency
of illumination to the eyes so it's
light goes on light goes off light goes
on light goes off at a frequency of 40
hertz
and when they did that and they recorded
the activity of neurons within the brain
not just within the visual areas of the
brain but within other areas as well
they observed
increased gamma oscillations
meaning that the electrical activity of
the brain at large started to match to
the patterns of
light that were delivered to the eyes
this is really exciting and very unique
from the different types of
phototherapies that we've been talking
about up until now all the patterns of
phototherapy that we've been talking
about up until now involved constant
illumination with a given wavelength
here it is
wavelength generating patterns of
illumination light on light off light on
light off at a particular frequency
so what they found for instance using
this pattern of stimulation and by the
way the stimulation was called genus
gamma entrainment using sensory
stimulation so genus gamma entrainment
using sensory stimulation
had a number of really interesting
effects first of all it reduced
so-called amyloid plaques
and phosphorylated tau amyloid plaques
and phosphorylated tau are associated
with alzheimer's and normal age-related
cognitive decline
so this is incredible right
a pattern of flashing light delivered to
the eyes creates a pattern of neuronal
firing not just in the visual areas of
the brain but in other areas of the
brain as well
that in turn trigger molecular pathways
that reduce some of the
markers and the cause of age-related
cognitive decline and alzheimer's and in
parallel to that they observed an
upregulation of some of the biological
pathways that lead to enhancement of
neuronal function maintenance of
synapses which are the connections
between neurons and so on and so on
they have discovered and list out a huge
number of these biological effects both
the reduction in bad things so to speak
and the improvement in good biological
pathways
and i find these studies so exciting
because first of all they're
non-invasive right there's no drilling
through the skull
they are very tractable in the
experimental sense meaning that you can
imagine
that if 40 hertz stimulation turns out
to be the very best stimulation protocol
to induce these gamma oscillations well
great but because it's non-invasive it's
fairly easy to explore 50 hertz
stimulation 100 hertz stimulation 20
hertz stimulation and to do that
with different wavelengths of light and
so that's what's happening now the
scilab and other labs are really
starting to explore the full range of
variables that can impact
oscillations within the brain and their
downstream consequences so again this is
phototherapy but phototherapy of a very
different sort that we've been talking
about up until now
it's phototherapy designed to trigger
activation of biological pathways far
away from the very tissue that's being
illuminated and it calls to mind the
same sorts of mechanisms that we were
talking about earlier where illumination
of the skin with uvb light is setting
off an enormous number of different
cascades in different organs and tissues
including the spleen the testes the
ovaries and so on
so
again light has these powerful effects
both locally on the cells that the light
is delivered to but also systemically in
terms of the cells that are changing
their electrical and chemical outputs
are modifying lots and lots of
biological programs is there an
actionable tool related to these studies
yet well that sort of depends on how
adventurous you are right now these
studies are being explored in the
context of clinical trials in people
with alzheimer's dementia and other
forms of neuronal degeneration
is it dangerous to look at a 40 hertz
flickering light
well
in general the answer is going to be no
however if you're prone to epilepsy for
instance staring at a flickering light
of a given continuous frequency can
induce seizure right that might surprise
some of you but it shouldn't because
as this study illustrates and as
anyone who's ever been out at night to a
club or something illustrates
when you look at a strobe light for
instance your whole world of visual
perception changes but actually the
rhythm
at which you perceive music at which you
perceive conversation at which you
perceive the movement of your body
actually changes according to the
patterns of visual flicker in most cases
strobe if we're using the sort of club
dancing example
your brain is in training to its outside
environment so given the power of
flickering lights to entrain brain
rhythms i think at this stage it's
probably too preliminary to really
suggest a specific protocol but i would
definitely keep an eye out for these
sorts of studies
they are coming out all the time and i
think in a very short period we're going
to see specific protocols that one could
potentially use even at home and of
course these are non-invasive protocols
in order to place the brain into a
particular state not just for sake of
offsetting neurodegeneration but also
for enhancing focus for enhancing the
transition into sleep and other brain
states as well today i covered
what i would say is a lot of information
my goal was to give you an understanding
of how light can be used to change the
activities of cells organelles within
those cells
entire organs and how that can happen
locally and systemically
we talked about the power of light to
impact our biology at the endocrine
level neuronal level immune level mood
etc
through both
illumination of the eyes and the skin
and other tissues as well
i realized that even though this was a
lot of information there are many
aspects of phototherapy that i did not
cover
i know there's a lot of interest
nowadays for instance in the use of red
light and other wavelength light
therapies for ovarian health and
testicular health
in fact i get a lot of questions
such as can red light be used to improve
testosterone output and if so is that
best accomplished by shining red light
on the skin or directly on the gonads on
the testicles i'm going to cover those
data
at a future time right now the studies
that have been done in rodents i don't
think are easily enough translated to
humans and the studies that are
happening in humans now are exciting in
the sense that they hold a lot of
potential but
the data aren't clear yet
however the data using uvb on the skin
of
men and women in order to increase
hormone in particular testosterone and
estrogen output those data i think are
very exciting and very actionable we
talked about those earlier so if you
want more information on how
phototherapy can be used certainly we
will do another episode on phototherapy
in these other contexts if you're
learning from and are enjoying this
podcast please subscribe to our youtube
channel that's a terrific zero cost way
to support us in addition please
subscribe to the podcast on apple and
spotify and on apple you have the
opportunity to leave us up to a
five-star review
if you have questions or feedback or
comments or suggestions about topics
that you'd like us to cover in a future
podcast episode or guest that you would
like me to interview for the huberman
lab podcast please put all those
suggestions comments and questions in
the comments section on youtube we do
read all the comments in addition please
check out the sponsors that we mention
at the beginning of the episode that's
the best way to support this podcast in
addition we have a patreon it's
patreon.com
andrewhuberman and there you can support
the podcast at any level that you like
during today's podcast we didn't really
talk about supplements but we do talk
about supplements and their various uses
in many other episodes of the huberman
lab podcast while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
that reason we've partnered with thorn
t-h-o-r-n-e because thorn supplements
are of the very highest quality and
stringency if you'd like to see the
thorn supplements that i take you can go
to thorn.com
the letter u slash huberman and there
you can get 20 off any of the
supplements that i take and if you
happen to navigate deeper into the thorn
site through that portal thorne.com u
slash huberman you can also get 20 off
any of the other supplements that thorn
makes if you're not already following us
on instagram and twitter please do so
it's huberman lab on instagram it's also
huberman lab on twitter and at both
places i provide science and
science-based tools some of which
overlap with the content of this podcast
much of which is unique from the content
of this podcast if you're not already
subscribing to our newsletter you might
consider doing so it's the so-called
neural network newsletter you can find
it at hubermanlab.com just go into the
menu look up neural network newsletter
you provide us your email it is zero
cost we provide summaries of podcasts
summaries of actionable protocols and so
forth we do not share your email with
anybody else and we have a very clear
privacy policy there at that website if
you choose to explore it
i'm also pleased to announce that we
have some live events coming up so i
will be giving a lecture called the
brain body contract where i'll talk
about science and science-based tools
some of which overlap with the content
of the huberman lab podcast much of
which is unique and has never been
presented publicly before the first one
is going to be may 17 2022 in seattle
washington the second one is going to be
may 18th in portland oregon to access
tickets you can go to the link at
hubermannlab.comtour
so thank you once again for joining me
today for this deep dive discussion into
phototherapies meaning the power of
light to modulate our biology and health
and as always thank you for your
interest in science
[Music]